I'm very excited to introduce to you
today dr. Joel Wallach because what
you're about to hear in the next hundred
and twenty minutes or so is nothing
short of amazing our health is one of
the most valuable things we have we all
want to be healthy and happy yet with so
much information out there how do you
know who to listen to how do you know
who's telling the truth when it comes to
getting well dr. Wallach has degrees in
agriculture and veterinary science and
has been a physician for over 35 years
he was in charge of a monumental study
that did over 20,000 autopsies on
animals in humans and ten million blood
chemistry's he's written 14 books
he's been published 70 times all over
the world he was a Nobel Prize nominee
he sold over a hundred and eighty
million copies of his book and CD dead
doctors don't lie and he's had to sue
the FDA eight times for the right to
make certain health claims that are true
when he couldn't get doctors to take
note of the fact that the animal
industry eliminated almost every birth
defect and over nine hundred diseases in
animals with simple nutritional formulas
and that it should work the same way in
humans he became a physician himself his
work is now changing the lives of
millions of individuals around the world
if I told you that almost all chronic
diseases such as type 2 diabetes high
blood pressure heart disease arthritis
fibromyalgia obesity MS migraines eczema
psoriasis and almost everything else you
can think of was the result of
nutritional deficiencies and that you
could make them go away 100% would that
be of interest to you and your loved
ones if so the things you're going to
hear in the next two hours have the
power to change your life forever
without anything further let's turn
things over to dr. Wallach appreciate
the introduction all right I'm just
gonna start out just a quick reminder
the thing that makes my view different
is that I have a degree in agriculture
and an agriculture we don't have health
insurance for animals like we do people
and so we just had to get rid of the
diseases in agriculture we have
veterinarians who would take care of
animals and if he didn't fix it the
first time out to the farm the farm
never called you back in human medicine
they treat you for 25-30 years because
you have insurance insurance has been
the worst possible thing for human
health
because allowed doctor to use you for an
ATM machine even though their cure is
available they will treat you for 25
years even though there's cures
available there's no law requiring them
to cure there's a cure available okay
that's a huge problem as you're all
finding out now but you're gonna learn
some things today that will help you
take care of yourself and the people you
love and of course they also have a
degree in veterinary medicine I'm a
veterinarian I also have any degree in
compared pathologist I do autopsies and
animals and people I also have a degree
as a physician a genetic position I'm a
primary care physician in Oregon
licensed in Oregon and California for
thirty five years and what I do
differently from other doctors is I
treat people like dogs but they get
better because in the dogs we've learned
how to eliminate 900 different diseases
and dogs that still plague people we've
learned how to triple the lifespan of
dogs we didn't do that with organ
transplants and stem cells and Jake
linear proteins and wonder drugs we did
it simply putting vitamins minerals our
canned dog for their bags of dried dog
food and then we eliminate every birth
defect you can name and ten times that
many can't name eliminated all those
birth defects just by putting vitamins
minerals in their food there's not a
single birth defect you can name this
genetically transmitted although doctors
would tell you they are but there's not
a single genetically transmitted birth
defect they're all nutritional
deficiencies the embryo okay let's get
to work here we're going to divide this
into two pieces
number one I'm going to show you what
the problem is and then number two I'm
going to show you how to eliminate these
disease okay well Americans spend more
money we've been doing this since the
Second World War we spend more money for
healthcare than all the nations world
combined not more than any nation more
than all nations
there's 204 nations in the United
Nations and we spend more money each
year for healthcare than all of them
combined we spent just short of three
trillion dollars for a healthcare what
do we get for it we're 90 second in
healthfulness there's 91 other nations
whose peoples are healthier than us
according to our CDC the Center for
Disease Control of Atlanta Georgia we
ranked 60th and longevity there was 59
other nations whose peoples live along
us and God forgive us we ranked 41st in
live births and first month's
survivability of our babies December
2008 Time magazine cover article says
the annual checkup of American health
oops the sorry state of American Health
remember we're spending more money for
health care than all the nations the
world combined
and the only thing they can say on the
cover of Time magazine in December 2008
about our health care is the sorry state
of American health despite technological
advances as a medicine Americans are
less healthy we used to be our health is
declining okay it's getting worse more
doctors more pharmaceuticals more
insurance more of everything and getting
worse whereas yet is the next generation
our kids gonna be worse off experts in
medical schools tell us that our
children I could live as long as us if
things continue to go the way they're
going they're not saying that you're
gonna die at 75 and your kids are your
dad's seventy-two fifteen years from now
what they're saying is you are gonna be
burying your children or be standing
your gravesite bearing your children if
you don't change what's going on here
the doctors aren't going to change the
form of sugolite going to change we're
gonna have to do it now the most
important part of a human beings life in
the first 91 days of pregnancy that's
when the embryo after fertilization the
egg is fertilized by the sperm the
embryo goes down this assembly line 91
days it's assembled after that the rest
of the six months of pregnancy is just
building size it's like a car going down
the assembly line let's say the car is
going down the assembly let's say it's a
Rolls Royce I mean we're talking about a
quarter of a million dollar car or a
half a million dollar car when it gets
to the point where the fuel pump is
supposed to be installed there's no fuel
pump sir but the car keep it going down
the assembly line and then there's a
place where the headlights are not
supposed to be there keep going down the
assembly line comes off the line the car
will crank but it won't sir because no
if you'll get into it can't drive at
night because there's no lights that's
what happens call them birth defects
there's not a single birth defect that
genetic all birth defects are in fact
preventable we've done in the animal
industry so let's look at some of this
stuff just I don't think I was giving
you false figures when it comes to live
births and and first month survivability
of our babies were number 41 in the
world it says the u.s. a shame that is
not true that is not true
because you put up money you should
spend more money for health care than
all the other nations will combined so
it's not America
is the OBGYN shame if every OBGYN was
put in jail for six months every time
they had a baby born with a birth defect
at a pregnancy that they monitored after
a couple years of wouldn't many more
babies born with birth defects because
they'd learned what I'm gonna teach you
tonight so pay attention here okay now
whether you agree with sarah palin's
politics or not she was very powerful
woman she was a governor of Alaska she
was the vice presidential candidate for
this United States for a large party
political party and her OBGYN who
monitored her her pregnancy allowed her
pregnancy to result in a very I'm sure
very nice child but with Down syndrome
trisomy 21 Down syndrome is not a
genetically transmitted disease it's a
simple nutritional deficiency in the
first 10 minutes of pregnancy when a
woman misses two periods and then she
goes on prenatal vitamins is two months
too late the first 10 minutes of
pregnancy if you don't have everything
that baby needs one out of seven hundred
babies out of the millions of babies
that are born every year in America one
out of seven hundred babies in this
country are born with Down syndrome
somebody needs to go to jail here folks
totally unnecessary
have you heard of cerebral palsy there's
a cerebellum little part of the brain
controls your fine motor movement so you
can play the piano and stand on one foot
and balance yourself and all this kind
of stuff it's called the cerebellum and
when a baby's born it's about the size
of a tangerine if it's normal but babies
with sure of palsy there are cerebellums
the size of a grape not genetic it's
just when the baby's going down the
assembly line the stuff that was
necessary to make that cerebellum wasn't
there and it could be the size of a
grape it could be half the size of a
challenger een three-quarters of the
size of a tangerine extremely minor
serve of palsies or someone's modest
some mostly severe and some severe and
then there's some catastrophic like this
young lady totally preventable you see
the embryo starts out as a disc and then
it folds into a tube and all this stuff
going on if the things aren't there or
that's supposed to be you get these
defects and who should we blame should
we blame ourselves it's America shame no
no no no it's the OBGYNs
how much nutrition do they get zero yeah
in eight years of medical school to get
zero nutrition what is the most
important thing in the life of an embryo
nutrition somebody needs to go to jail
and then talk about all these cleft lip
cleft palates these are all simple
nutritional deficiencies of the embryo
when the baby is a flat disc it folds up
and it doesn't fold up all at once it's
kinda like a zipper this folding so it
starts out at the top and goes on down
to the bottom and you get belly button
hernias you get things like tidal
hernias in the diaphragm and you can
find a good Christian surgeon who will
donate his time to sew these little kids
up
it'll cost you $250 that save the
children two for each kid for the
anesthesia and the suture material to
sew them up so I can suck on a straw and
speak intelligibly they're not gonna
look beautiful like movie stars because
they're still gonna have massive scars
and things but these things are totally
preventable so now you're armed now
you're dangerous because you know
something and so when do you start a
child with all 90 essential nutrients
all 90 essential vitamins minerals well
before they're conceived before they're
conceived all through the pregnancy that
they're developed in from the moment
they're born and after one generation we
will never have a child with any birth
defect now how many Verte of genetics
DNA you know that double helix all that
kind of stuff well a double helix from
the DNA was identified in 1953 by James
Watson an American and Francis Crick a
Englishman and they were running up and
down we found it we know the secret of
life now if you have a genetic disease
like diabetes we can engineer in a test
tube a normal gene from you we can take
a stem cell freewill engineer a
perfectly normal gene for diabetes and
will replace your diabetes genes with it
and we'll get rid of your disease I mean
they were excited nine years later they
actually got the Nobel Prize for it for
mapping out this double helix structure
and I mean science went to work they
came up with 850 genetics tests 850
genetics tests right this is December
2012 cover article Time magazine I just
loved it the Time magazine knows more
than the medical trade they don't know
their Anatomy though they say this baby
is colon cancer gene is in his right
shoulder his glaucoma gene for blindness
in the eye is due
in his right knee and his prostate
cancer Gina's in his left knee well
guess what they have all these tests we
spent 1 trillion dollars that's a
thousand billion dollars we spent
mapping out the human genome how many
know in 2001 we did it we've mapped out
the human genome we know all the
sequence of all the things now right
that was 12 years ago now to the date
when they got their Nobel / dat 1953
Watson and Crick Watson 60 years to the
date March 22nd 2013 says that he was
speaking to the University of California
in San Diego and the Salk Institute and
he said gene sequence e is not the
solution to solving diseases the
solution is good chemistry means
vitamins & Minerals gene sequencing to
cure cancer and diabetes and obesity and
how the pressure and all this kind of
stuff is irrelevant everything they've
done the last six years of genetics the
guy who got the Nobel Prize for it says
it's irrelevant and I said that 1978
male laughed at me of course most on the
left of me are all dead but Watson said
you can sequence 150 thousand people a
day you're not going to cure cancer
diabetes or any other disease most of
the experiments we've done over the last
six years have been irrelevant because
none of its genetic so I have a book
coming out at the end of this year it's
my 14th book there's the cover of it
epigenetics the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission all the
diseases that are said to be genetic are
in here and shows you how to prevent
them how to reverse them okay here it
comes now be alert for this one this is
it now there's a very boring scientific
journal called food chemistry you pick
that thing up and you open up it's just
page after page of columns of numbers
and things just like caret and numbers
and beats and numbers and corn and
numbers what they do they send teams of
graduate students out to farms and they
personally harvest some carrots and
beets and corn and wheat and tomatoes
and beans and peas and then they run
them to the lab and they find out what
nutrition is in them and they found out
what pollutions in them then they follow
that farmers harvest to the stores and
they rerun it again for nutrition and
pollution and see what pollution was
added to it during the processing and
getting there and how much nutrition was
lost during the pack
and shipping and Rhian packaging and
putting on the store well in April 2012
April 16 this issued said commercial
available baby foods they looked at
eight of them we're talking about Gerber
Similac Enfamil very trusted names in
America
okay commercial available baby foods may
contain less than 20% of the recommended
levels and many minerals and vitamins
less than 20% laboratory rat food has
100% laboratory rabbit food has a
hundred percent chicken sheep pig horse
cow food has 100 percent your babies
here and babies have less than 20
percent why is that because the medical
trade and eight years of medical school
gets no nutrition they just train them
how to take your credit card and how to
prescribe prescriptions that's it this
is the cause of most of our problems
right here and so now I'm gonna tell you
remember I have a degree in agriculture
I'm a veterinarian I'm a compared
pathologist one project for a National
Institutes of Health at Emory University
I did over twenty thousand autopsies 20
million chemistry's is published in a
twelve hundred page book that's in the
Smithsonian Institute is a national
treasure and then went on became a
physician because it couldn't get
doctors do what I was saying to do so I
wouldn't did it myself
sometimes you just got to do it and so
that's where I come from well in
veterinary industry we eliminated 900
different diseases still plague people
not with wonder drugs and stem cells and
organ transplants and Jaclyn's your
proteins we did it simply by putting
vitamins and minerals in their dog food
eliminate every birth defects you can
name in ten times that many you can't
just simply by putting vitamins minerals
and her dog food we've tripled their
lifespan six years ago when an old dog
was eight years old today told dog is 25
we do that simply by putting vitamins
and minerals there dog food and so I
decided to treat people like dogs and
you know what they got better Newsweek
magazine cover story and that's but
missed most people's our initial we
actually get a little giggle out of this
kid he thinks he's won the lottery he's
pledging this nice warm envelope full of
super-sized french fries he is one happy
kid right
but he's doomed he says when I grow up
I'm gonna weigh 300 pounds help it's not
genetic it's actually a simple
nutritional deficiency disease I don't
know how many of you know this but I
actually wrote a book is I don't know
ninth early 2004 something
that called Hell's Kitchen it was
actually based on a sermon that I gave
my own church in San Diego and the
pastor gave me permission we have a CD
of it and I said pastor I want to call
it Hell's Kitchen he thought for me said
well yeah so I thought he was cool and
somebody sell millions that little CD in
the book a Hell's Kitchen goes into all
the proof that obesity is a simple
nutritional to finish disease now how
many of you know that were the number
one obese nation in the world spend more
money for health care than all the
nation's world combined and the only
thing we can brag about being number one
in the area of health is where the most
obese nation in the world is what does
that tell you about what the medical
system knows about obesity
Mediterraneans know everything about it
I can make prime beef I can make beef or
no fat on it so I use the same
principles right 1978 I started it's a
simple nutritional deficiency we do this
thousands of times a day now we get
people to lose 140 pounds in a hundred
days to get people to lose 90 pounds in
75 days we have thousands of people
every day to lose 50 pounds in a couple
of months very simple stuff once you
know what button to push is easy now
here comes the beauty of this whole
thing
June 20th 2013 the AMA declared obesity
disease well hallelujah see prior to
that time they said obesity is just
people making bad choices and food and
lack of exercise in too much screentime
and all that kind of stuff no it's a
simple nutritional deficiencies I'm
gonna prove that to you here in a minute
it's a simple you take the nutrients it
just goes away it's real simple now I
guarantee you they didn't do this out of
the goodness of their heart that they
did clear disease and here's why I say
this
LaMichael system cause of this this new
health care thing coming on is hurting
particularly specialist:a Medicare when
the doctor bills Medicare for 100 bucks
a Medicare only pays them 20 so the
primary care physicians the family
doctors aren't referring patients out
anymore you know a primary care
physician could do a hip replacement
operation there's no law that says he
can't primary care physician can write
prescriptions for radiology to do heart
tests and he can then prescribe you the
same drugs as a specialist would and so
suddenly now the family doctors are
keeping the the complicated patients
as Medicare's not paying much anymore so
the specialists are starving they're
looking around they're selling their
businesses to hospitals hospitals are
tripling the price as a test and
prosthesis and surgeries and and
procedures and drugs because they have
no competition on the field anymore so
they just triple the price once they
bought up the last doctor practice in
town they just triple the price they
have no competitors anymore yep lovely
now so why then did doctors declare
obesity disease because insurance pays
for diseases they said well we're we're
all the fish at will the fish are in
obesity and so will declare disease now
so insurance will pay for it now we can
make our house payment that's why they
did it's not because of the goodness of
their heart Henry heard ADT ADHD and
autism it has nothing to do with
vaccinations those things have anything
to a vaccination I'm a pathologist so I
do crazy things I looked at batch
numbers that nobody else did before I
look at batch numbers in vaccination
there's only a you know less than a
dozen manufacturers of childhood
vaccinations and then they read a
private label them to all these
distribution companies and everything
he's the same raw material to have the
same batch numbers no matter what whose
labels are there these are the same
batch numbers and they use the same
batch numbers in Africa and Asia and
Europe and North America and Central
America and South America but 95% of all
autism ATD and ADHD 95% is in this
country so it's not the vaccinations
let's see remember food chemistry April
16 2012 our babies are getting less than
20% of the nutrients they require your
brain requires nutrients so you're
getting less I mean there's no nutrition
and Fruity Pebbles and apple juice
there's no nutrition to sugar frosted
flakes and Welch's grape juice there's
no nutrition in a goes our instant
oatmeal and Sunny Delight that's why we
have all these problems these kids
because their brains are dying of
malnutrition not vaccinations
how many heard alzheimers disease raise
your hand this article came out
obviously February this year said
Elmer's patients could triple by 2050
well I guarantee and they are because an
eighty million baby boomers come along
who are reaching that age or over 65 no
and so there's 80 million um that's one
third of our population
a triple and it's just your simple
fourth grade math has not the big deal
right doctors say help us we need to
find something to help us keep the
number of Alzheimers patients down to
thirteen point eight million a year I'm
gonna show you how to eliminate it
because it's a physician caused disease
Alison Rosie's did not exist in any way
shape or form in 1942 today it's number
four killer of adults over the age of 65
look at who owns all the hospices
medical doctors now here comes the
medical doctor I thought politicians are
bad but medical doctors are the only
people who can say three lies in the
same sentence Alzheimers is the only
disease amongst the top six killers in
the USA for which there's no prevention
cure treatment that none of those three
are true doctors are so terrible when it
comes to dementia if you reach the age
of 65 one in three of Americans who
reach age 65 will die from dementia they
suck when it comes to this my grandkids
are saying now why do our kids die
before we do well right now there's more
kids under the age of 18 dying of stroke
in America than people over the age of
65 that's because stroke is not a
genetic stroke is not an accidental
thing or just some dumb thing happening
actually sue the FDA over this and I
have prevailed but doctors don't pay
attention to those sorts of things they
keep doing what they do right so what
causes stroke it's a deficiency of
our a racial problem between omega-3
6009 I actually sued the FDA over this
to be able to say you can supplement
with omega-3s and actually reduce and
eliminate trauma body stroke blood clots
in the brain coronary thrombosis
pulmonary embolism and deep vein
thrombosis before I sued the FDA in
federal court and prevailed with my own
money no no we didn't have any
organization it was my money because I
couldn't stand it anymore you see
there's no omega-3s in Cheerios or
oatmeal or Sunny Delight you don't only
say before I sue them you can only say
eating foods rich in omega threes could
reduce the risk of thrombotic stroke and
karna thrombosis
I had to sue them to be able to say like
I'm telling you tonight you can
supplement properly and guarantee you're
never going to have that problem
okay now I'm 74 years old I've never
been to a doctor in the last 65 years
never
prescription medication I don't have any
health problems nobody's gonna steal an
airplane with me on it I find it amusing
that they'll take your finger a little
clipper away from you and I can kill
three people in a minute with my
ballpoint pen government is typically
stupid right AARP American Association
retired people they're marketing to 55
year-olds now I love that okay March
2012 little over a year ago cover
article the worst place to be in America
when you're sick is an American Hospital
I took two pieces out of the article and
says the number of American patients who
die each year from American Hospital
Aires is equal to four jumbo just
crashing each week say 1,500 people
3,000 every two weeks six thousand a
month 72,000 a year if you knew that
commercial airlines killed 72,000
passengers a year how many of you would
fly I gotta go see my doctor I gotta go
see my doctor I gotta go see my doctor
okay then they also said in that article
each US Surgeon operates on the wrong
person wrong body part as often as 40
times a week even a three-year-old knows
left from right that was in March in
December of 2012
each Surgeon United States makes
thousands of errors they get a walk and
then why is that
19:14 almost exactly a hundred years ago
medical doctors legislated themselves
into a protected monopoly there was a
thing called the flexion report back in
1914 they legislated themselves into a
protected monopoly they're the only
legal monopoly in America they
legislated not only did they legislate
themselves into being a monopoly but
they legislated all their competition
into being quacks if you're not an MD or
a quack the federal government the state
government the county and city only
recognizes MDS the military only
recognizes MDS
if they have failed as terribly ranked
92nd in the world in health wellness
we're ranked 60th longevity and we
ranked 41st librarian and first one
survival over babies there's no
competition you see I can't go to a
public meeting and say you don't have to
take drugs for diabetes for 30 years and
go blind get your legs cut off and have
25 years your life go away and gain too
much weight and all this kind of stuff
with a little simple nutritional program
which we call a healthy blood sugar pack
you
there's over a hundred billion dollars
or the research into that healthy blood
sugar packs ounds pretty simple healthy
blood sugar pecker there's a hundred
billion dollars of the research in that
we've known for seventy years it's a
simple mineral deficiencies you take
this within four to six weeks you'll be
off for your medication will be annexed
i abetik is that simple Newsweek
magazine cover article August 2011 the
one word that will save your life in a
hospital it's a two letter word that
every two-year-old knows know okay we've
given you six rounds of chemotherapy now
you have three minutes to live we want
to try this new experimental drug on you
that's because the FDA requires them to
tell them how many people out of every
hundred they give the drug to how many
are killed by the drug they're using you
as a guinea pig when they say you've
only got weeks to live and we want to
try this an experimental drug oh and you
have to find out if it kills you or not
and so you should say no would you
rather last two weeks your life would
you rather be in your own bed with your
dog on your lap hugging your grandkids
instead of your grandkid come to the
hospital because everybody knows you
only have days or weeks to live and the
nurse says I'm sorry honey you can't go
in to see your grandma now she's being
killed by the doctor because they're
translate so you can't see your you
can't see grandma now she's intensive
care what kind of nonsense is that stop
taking them to a hospice hospice nurses
will come to your home do Hospice at
home don't give those doctors every last
penny the family has that's the
centerfold from that issue a Newsweek
magazine what is he afraid of this is a
universal fear posture right no matter
what language you speak no matter what
color you are that this is a fear
posture
well there's spaceman or Godzilla or
whatever right and so what is he afraid
of well Thai there's seven doctors on
the opposing page coming to him I want
you look at them and see if they're
coming to them him with a good Christian
heart they look like a scene from the
night of The Walking Dead TV series
that's because he's the only one in the
hospital with money they're all after
him everybody else in the hospital is a
Medicare patient and they don't want
them they'll kill each other
trying to get to him Reader's Digest
very warm fuzzy magazine you'll find it
in all professional waiting rooms
whether they're an attorney or an
architect or a doctor of veterinary and
a dentist everybody has Reader's Digest
you can't even need to read it you know
there could be warm fuzzy stories dog
drags a two-year-old out of the house
during a fire for
girl calls 911 grandma's life that's the
kind of stuff you find Reader's Digest
well in June of 2007 possible mistakes
you can avoid look at the font sizes
blood-red it's screaming at you read
this thing do you think every doctor
made sure this issue is in their waiting
room
I don't think so I spent 20 years in the
Air Force myself I love veterans and
this study came out it was from the
Department of Veterans Affairs did this
study it was a self-study
okay it came out in December of 1997
they publish to the public in 1999
hundreds of thousands of mistakes each
year in the VA system three thousand
which are serious where they take out
the healthy lung we leave the cancerous
lung in you go in for a hemorrhoid
operation and they take your cerebellum
out of your brain or something you know
did really dumb stuff and and three
thousand those mistakes are that serious
the the person either dies in the
hospital or they are required to stay
another year well look at what the
department veteran affairs said about
700 of these 3,000 major mistakes they
kill they kill 700 you know how many
American servicemen and women were
killed last year in Afghanistan 380
medical doctors in the VA system killed
more American servicemen and women every
year than the enemy when do you get
angry enough to do something about it
okay we have to do something and what
it's going to take is for us to stop
going to them but to take care of our
loved ones we have to take care of
herself last year we set a record and
more servicemen returning kill
themselves than the last ten years
combined that's because they live on
MREs there's nothing more than a meal
bar and distilled water no vitamins and
minerals so if you have anybody in the
service in your family or in your church
you need to be sending them the 90
essential nutrients they'll come home to
be okay you're out there carrying those
80 pound packs they sweat they don't get
any nutrition they sweat out all that
nutrition this is one of my favorite
stories that came out February 2007 look
at the title page to protect themselves
kind of vanilla the data that we share
with you came from the journal the
American Medical Association the most
prestigious medical journal in America
maybe the world in the Center for
Disease Control again that federal
agency that tracks this kind of stuff
in Atlanta Georgia and they said this
article said using those two agencies as
their source of informations and said
each year in America each year each year
in America medical doctors kill injured
in fact 15 milder customers at workplace
each in American medical doctors kill
injured in fact 15 mill and their
customers at workplace 5.8 million in
households and 9.2 million in the
private office and Clinics how many of
you fly commercial airlines if you knew
that they killed injured infected 15
million passengers every year
nobody would fly so we went to war in
Afghanistan because the bad guys killed
3,000 New Yorkers here's one group of
tradesmen here in this country
yearly kill injured in fact 15 million
got a few more of these and I think
you'll have the picture then we'll get
to the diseases but I think you need to
know what the problem is on being a
veterinarian and a physician this is
important to me this one remember I said
each in America according to the Center
for Disease Control which they also did
this study Center for Disease Control in
Atlanta and the journal American Medical
Association medical doctors each year in
their workplace kill injured infect 15
million well in the hospitals remember
this is just the hospitals this does not
include clinics in the house was 2
million infections each year of those 2
million infections each year 90,000 died
ok now I'm gonna show you if people say
that he's exaggerating what do I show
you this you haven't seen the next slide
yet now how does that happen how can
that happen in a hospital supposed to be
a refuge a place of safety and so near 8
what happens is they wear the same white
coat the same panty hose the same
trousers the same shoes room to room to
room
dragging snot pee poop blood pus viruses
bacteria fungus and yeast by contrast in
a pig barn by federal law Brent this was
spread of swine flu if you're a visitor
or worker every morning when you go into
that barn if take a shower with
disinfectant soap for like five minutes
you tear open a bag with a clean pair of
coveralls and boots and before you go
from one Pigpen to the next you're
required to stand for four minutes and a
four inch deep tub of disinfectant and
then brush your boots off with a brush
before you go to the next Pigpen we
treat pigs in a barn better we treat
human beings at a hospital in this
country ok this came out in August of
2012 about 10 months ago now one
bacteria CEDIA
classroom difficile which is a human
poop bacteria so it's only found in
human poop of those ninety thousand
deaths each year from infections in
hospital thirty thousand one third of
them occur because doctors don't wash
their hands
in 1993 there were eighty five thousand
seven hundred these see diff infections
reported in hospitals thirty thousand
which result in death 17 years later
2010 it went up four hundred percent to
three hundred three hundred fifty
thousand three hundred forty six
thousand eight hundred does this chart
give you some sense that they're working
hard to prevent the problem no there's
no consequences why should they wash
their hands if they're doing the right
thing that chart should look like that
this is what you're getting and your
hospitals folks well let's look at
pharmaceuticals well everybody loves
pharmaceuticals and we have war on
street drugs and of course for the last
50 years
the pharmaceutical industry and the
medical doctors have been after the FDA
to report adverse events route calls on
herbs vitamins and minerals so in 2007
they did it for the first time reported
in 2008 there was 600 adverse event
calls of course these the pharmaceutical
industry and the medical doctors assured
the FDA was going to be in the thousands
400 adverse events reports for herbs and
none of them were fatality they were
like fast heart rate from too much green
tea and a you know mixture are they got
maybe a skin from something 200 these
were adverse events from vitamins
minerals somebody takes too much vitamin
C they get diarrhea they take too much
niacin vitamin b3 they get itchy rashy
skin no deaths well the same year in
2007 which they've been doing for 50
years they reported not to the public
but in the mortality and morbidity
reports which come out every week right
they reported it for the pharmaceuticals
prescription drugs now is in this report
here but it's very difficult to see it's
down here in the corner so I blew it up
because most people by the time they get
to here they're not gonna read the whole
thing so they purposely put it down here
very tiny little thing yeah I blew it up
so you can compare this 600 adverse
events reports non fatalities with 480
to 154 adverse events reports for
prescription drugs that same year all of
these were fatalities you tell me what's
more dangerous pharmaceuticals or
vitamins and minerals but but but it's
fda-approved people always ask me well
are your vitamins and minerals FDA
approved I say drop your knees and give
thanks to Lord they're not because
everything the FDA approves kills people
every drug the FDA approved every drug
even baby aspirin has a little warning
on there one of the side effects may be
death this is a yearly figure and this
is another look at the pharmaceutical
thing that's my medication error rising
now they're not talking about the side
effects of the drugs here they're
talking about decimal point errors which
I'm sure the pharmacists thank God catch
some of that stuff when it comes in and
then of course doctors will prescribe
three or four different drugs are the
same patient particularly older people
because insurance pays and they get a
kickback right and so they do that and
they of course you get potentiation and
that combination will kill the patient
these types of medication errors each
year are tied to one point five million
fatalities and permanent injuries okay
you only you can stop this when the
period but doctor writes prescriptions
tear it up and from Satan
sorry okay this is the last one of this
kind of really bad series and we'll move
on to the next subject this came out in
2010 hospital care fatal for some
patients that's kind of vanilla
results of Medicare study alarming
what's alarming the study was actually
done by the US Department of Health and
Human Services Office of Inspector
General
okay so this study was done by the US
Department of Health and Human Services
Office of Inspector General which is the
auditor from Medicare okay what they
said was that each month not each year
each month in America medical doctor has
killed 15,000 Medicare patients from
simple tests and minors minor procedures
they killed 15,000 Medicare patients
each month that's a hundred and eighty
thousand a year if you're age 65 and you
knew the commercial airlines killed
180,000 seniors over age 65 every year
you'd say honey cancel the airplane
flight I turned 65 yesterday we're going
to Amtrak I'm going to show you three
people
three people very famous people who died
as seniors at the hands of doctors for
minor procedures Andy Rooney 60 minutes
retired at 92 is a wife is 87 they're
gonna go on a world cruise for a year
and she was a little nervous she said
look we can't speak half those languages
the place we're going we need to take a
disk of our health care stuff in case we
get sick or the head agent oh he said
okay so they go to the doctor and molder
waiting for the disk to be cut with all
their medical records in it the doctors
rooting through Andy's medical records
says in a year 92 years old and I can't
find review of ever had a colon was
copping exam you can have cancer lurking
around in yet I wasn't there of course
but I could I know Andy Rudy because he
used to watch him every Sunday on 60
minutes I just loved his sense of humor
and III can see him saying well I don't
know blood my bowel mom and I haven't
had to change my bowel habits in the
last 10 years I haven't lost anyway
don't hate pelvic pain I don't think I
have any colon cancer he that's what he
should have said but I'm sure the doctor
insisted and he should have said Andy
should have said no who said he said
being a compliant 90 year old he said
okay comes in the next day the doctor
sticks a garden hose up his rump
punctures intestine three days later
he's dead from peritonitis belly
infection wife's a widow and he never
went on his trip now when you look at
his obituary you can look it up online
it says mr. Rooney died from
complications of a minor medical
procedure one minor for him had killed
him
Dick Clark the guy who discovered the
Jackson 5 and Michael Jackson the
world's oldest teenager kind of guy 82
years old goes in for his physical
complains to his doctor he gets up three
or four times a night to take a pee
because you know there he's that age
eight years old the doctors wait
probably about prostate problems send
you down the hall when I'm done with him
we got a urologist take care of you
Rollins his exams yeah I got enlarged
prostate here if you lump some bumps on
it we can take it out I can push it
ahead a list I can do it tomorrow
morning 11:00 o'clock and he says why I
didn't reach my age by going to surgery
of everything is do you have a
prescription that doesn't work this and
this is outpatient procedure no big deal
you come in at 11 o'clock 11:30
redundant one o'clock her in the golf
course we do this all the time no big
deal
and and Dick Clark should have said no
but instead he said okay goes in 11
o'clock the next morning 11:30 s dead
30,000 men in America each year 30
man in America each year died within an
hour after the procedure because when
you cut on the prostate gland either
with a knife or scissors or stick it
with a large biopsy needle releases a
hormone called prostaglandin which
increases your risk of death from
coronary thrombosis ternary thrombotic
stroke and he won the lottery and had
both my favorite though is Neil
Armstrong our top astronaut first man to
walk on the moon he personally saved two
doomed NASA missions saved the
spacecraft saved the cruise but because
of his technical knowledge on how to
communicate with the machinery and the
equipment in a spacecraft from a
computer on earth I mean we have more
information and more technology in this
little smartphone than they had on the
spaceships right but he had enough he
could save those two crews he goes in
for his physical eight years old the
doctors came out and said astronaut
Armstrong that NASA program must be
wonderful you're eight years old you
have perfect healthy you don't have any
symptoms of any kind your laboratory
worlds work is perfect the other thing
we can find one corner ivory is 30%
blocked not going to cause angina no
chest pain that I was to be getting a
heart attack from at a very low but if
you wait five or six or eight years it's
a progressive thing we get worse you
could dive going to the hospital the
heart attack blah blah blah you're fit
now you should let us put a stint in
there do a bypass you'll never have a
heart attack from that artery he should
have said no instead he said okay let's
do it
three days later he was dead from
complications resulting from a elective
cardiovascular seizure and unnecessary
cardiovascular procedure we clean that
artery out in just a couple of weeks
there was no investigation by NASA there
was no investigation by the state a New
York State Medical Society there's no
investigation by the hospital Medical
Board
what if al-qaeda would have kidnapped
him cut his head off on YouTube we have
sent in drones we'd have sent in SEAL
team number six somebody would have died
if they killed our top astronaut but if
doctors do it it's okay okay
cholesterol there's not a single
diseases caused by elevated blood
cholesterol normal cholesterol for a
human being is 220 to 270 where'd I get
that figure it's from a set he was done
back in the 1950s at the University of
California San Francisco Steven B Holley
was the guy who days a cardiologist and
he's also an F
geologist he looked at 300,000 people
all those 300,000 6% had blood
cholesterol is below 200 for start of a
study for 20 years he thought they were
gonna be the ones they have the fewest
cardiovascular events and live the
longest well the ones who lived the
longest and didn't have any
cardiovascular ones who had cholesterol
to 20 to 70 he reported that the journal
the American Medical Association know
how many doctors pay attention to it
zero because they all these cute little
gals coming from the pharmaceutical
companies and there's a little
miniskirts the doctors taking them out
to lunch and they all write
prescriptions for mevacor lipitor zocor
and all those core things right they
lower your cholesterol well I actually
did a study when you do 20,000 autopsies
in 10 min chemistry's you have a lot of
mature I wrote 75 scientific papers Plus
that book out of the deal one of my
papers was I compared the coronary
artery plugging and vegetarians and
vegans versus meat-eaters guess who had
the worst plugged arteries vegans
because cholesterol has nothing to do
with it nothing what plugs your arteries
in inflammation how many heard of the
inflammation thing that's getting to be
new around right well I said that 1971
was published in an international
pathology journal in eight languages it
was published in Denmark I went around
the world everybody I had thousands of
calls then nobody did anything he used
to hang around 25 pathologist we all go
to the continued education together kind
of buddies you know we'd have dinner
together and party together and they all
laughed at me said well like you must be
sniffin glue everybody knows it's
cholesterol I said no no I did all these
autopsies and the ones who are the worst
or the vegans and vegetarians because
they stir-fry everything in coconut oil
and olive oil they use a lot of salad
dressings for calories because they
don't get enough calories don't have any
dense food like meat and so there
they're using all these oils as a source
of calories
trans fatty acids hair psychic amines
acrylamide cause inflammation it all
respond by plugging well that was in
1971 here we are February 2012 year and
a half ago federal health officials are
adding new safety warnings about the
risk of statin drugs the widely
prescribed route of cholesterol-lowering
medications if you take a statin drug to
lower your cholesterol every day for ten
years and you aren't a cholesterol
restricted diet every day for ten years
increase your risk of bowel disease by
100 percent you're gonna get it
and here's why what is else Rosie's
Allyson disease is it going away on the
myelin the white matter of the brain
makes up 75% your brain wait it's the
insulation material in the brain okay
when it goes away the naked nerve fibers
tangle up and they charge circuiting you
get Alison receipt now I can take a
brain at autopsy and I can never read
the clinical record and I can tell you
by looking at that brain under the
microscope if there's nerve tangles in
there I can tell you that person had
Alison disease just by looking at slides
of the brain I don't even need to hear
the clinical record right because that's
what we call a Pathak mnemonic lesion
it's a lesion that's drop-dead
predictable as gravity that that's it
there's no other option and then of
course that same scenario will increase
your risk of type 2 diabetes by 52
percent what disease is costing us the
most money in America right now diabetes
or Al's patients are your triple because
all the baby boomers come along who
lived on egg beaters and egg white
omelets and boneless skinless chicken
breast and oils and margarine instead of
butter cream and lard and tofu and beans
instead of red meat federal countries
don't have Alzheimers disease because
they're eating meat in June of that same
year 2012 science news very respectable
journal good cholesterol nuts are
beneficial I want you to email your
doctor to say I just saw something in
science news and said good cholesterol
is not so beneficial he will scream you
know you know like they do on the
females and go crazy what that can't be
true high ratio high density lipoprotein
is a good closure levels don't reduce
heart attacks
that's because cholesterol has nothing
with heart attacks bless your blood
cholesterol is 200 and 100 percent of
its HDL the good cholesterol you won't
reduce your risk of heart attacks
cholesterol has nothing to as heart
attacks when you lower your cholesterol
you have cholesterol above 300 remember
220 to 70s normal you want it to be in
between 222 7300 just means you're
sexier because you ever hear us see our
ID hormones testosterone estrogen
progesterone 95% steroid hormones is
cholesterol you've gone the cholesterol
restricted diet you give up eggs ain't
nobody home anymore
women used to go through menopause and
they're seven years old in 3 seconds now
women go through menopause in 30 years
they accept prescription drugs it caused
breast cancer you know the hormones and
everything over there bioidentical
that's just like saying but the bullet
is led you know it's copper-jacketed
there's not a single medical screening
test to prevent
disease there's not a single medical
screening test that prevents the disease
The Globe and Mail is the USA Today
equivalent in Canada I speak a lot up
there probably about a month and a half
and you count all the days out of each
year screening is not prevention ok
mammograms of course are one of the
things that women submit to this was a
30 year study a three decade study
Harvard Medical School published in the
journal the American Medical Association
to be the New England Journal of
Medicine and it was published last year
in November 2012 and here's the results
said in women over 40 1.3 million of
them over the past three years actually
had false positives that amounted 31% of
all women diagnosed the breast cancer
with a mammogram 31% were false
positives this is in the New England
Journal Medicine November 2012 the worst
year was 2008 where they had 70,000
false positives they cut these women's
breasts off they give them chemotherapy
and radiation they put them the cure
column they know they didn't have it and
these women run around like Judas goats
all you have to go to dr. so-and-so he's
so good he caught my cancer early with a
mammogram and once you get a mammogram
he said well mammograms are safe they
have less radiation in a triple-a
battery well they came out three months
ago and said one mammogram has the same
amount of radiation as 500 chest x-rays
you know you can do a better job at self
breast examination even if you were 20
years into menopause your self breast
exam keep a log of 15th of every month
at 10 o'clock in the morning you find
something new you find something that
tender that didn't used to be tender go
yourself without the doctor you go to a
radiology laboratory you ask for a
high-resolution ultrasound no radiation
and it's actually more accurate leave
the doctor out of the loop here is where
the insurance fraud comes in a push to
prevent colorectal cancer get your colon
scopic exam doesn't prevent it oh you
had polyps published just means you're
eating too much deli slices and too much
sandwich meats and too many hot dogs too
much pastrami and your pepperoni pizza
okay has nothing to do polyps don't
become cancer PSA tests a federal panel
says now no PSA test anymore guys do not
do it why because just like Dick Clark
two things happen you're gonna be the
one of those 30,000 die
within now right for the surgery are you
gonna be one of the 200 300 thousand
that become permanently impotent and to
get Edie permanently and their income
they just pee all over themselves
it gives new meaning to the term dirty
smelly old man June 4th 2012 Time
magazine health science section skipped
the PSA screen experts say PSA blood
test for posi cancer doesn't save lives
that's because was never meant to be a
screen for prostate cancer most
important part a warren buffett's
announcement that he who diagnosed with
prostate cancer was this paragraph down
here richard Amblin the scientist who
discovered PSA calls the testes
widespread use a public health disaster
the guy who invented it calls it a
public health disaster that's because it
doesn't diagnose prostate cancer and you
can actually through an examination you
can actually make it go up that's why he
calls it richard Appling calls it the
guy who invented it calls it a public
health disaster ok well now we're going
to switch to diet I think you got an
idea that doctors and hospitals are
dangerous pharmaceuticals are dangerous
you're not your first choice you have to
take some responsibility here ok this is
a Harvard study they did in 1990 for
males and females in America came out in
1997 of the public and what they looked
at was lifespans county-by-county
they're gonna do is find out which
County lived the longest in America I
thought was kind of clever and then they
were going to find out what medical care
what medical services they had there
they're gonna duplicate that in all the
other counties in America and an upgrade
our average lifespan now from a
superficial standpoint say well man that
that's pretty cool they're thinking
about America but they knew that they
were gonna have to increase the amount
of medical care and every other County
right what they didn't plan on was they
found out that every county in America
has the same medical care you can live
under the bridge and be homeless and
illiterate never worked a day in your
life didn't ever have any insurance you
crawl into an emergency room you will
get the same care that a billionaire
gets not because doctors love you and
they're outsourcing they're good
Christians they give them this this guy
living under the bridge it's a medical
care that a that a billionaire gets
because insurance pays what they found
out was the longest-lived people in
America are in the purple in the Midwest
the Upper Midwest in the upper plane
states the shortest-lived people in
America in the Old Confederate states
plus Cook
County Chicago in Lake County and Gary
Indiana everything West in Mississippi
River is in an Indian Reservation the
yellow orange and red these are those
shortest-lived people the people in them
and the purple they live 25 years longer
than the purple is not genetic but they
did find out it was how they eat these
people in the purple counties are all
people from Scandinavia Norwegians Swiss
Swedes Finnish Danish Austrians they
cook everything by roasting stewing
grilling how they cook in the Old South
and in Cook County in Lake County if you
never again eat fried foods if you never
again give your children or
grandchildren your nieces and nephews
your pride chicken you'll add 25 years
to life if you don't even give me any
bottoms if you just don't ever eat fried
foods again that's what this say there's
a Harvard study well 23 years later 23
years later the University of Wisconsin
repeated it dietary habits not hospitals
affect how County's healthcare rank they
picked Pennsylvania because it was the
worst in the best it was a good bad and
the ugly Philadelphia County or the City
Philadelphia's then obviously first in
health care we're talking about most
doctors per patient more households more
cat scan machines more pharmacists more
prosthesis I mean more of everything
more massage therapists right but it had
the worst overall health you see it's
not hospitals with exception of bleeding
emergencies that's where they shine as
Bleeding emergencies but when it comes
to diabetes and I would pressure and
heart disease they know nothing when it
comes to obesity they know nothing they
don't know anything there but all
they're taught to do is prescribe drugs
they don't know I can't forgive them for
that because they've had a hundred years
for somebody to stand back and say you
know or killing more people than the
enemy we need to stop what we're doing
until we figure out a better way why is
a dumb farm boy from Missouri the one
that's doing it this guy's been dead for
35 years he's still killing people fried
food causes trans fatty acids and he
recycled amines acrylamide they cause
cancer there's no doubt about that
the FDA knows that they keep preaching
it everybody keeps going to Kentucky
Fried Chicken so here's what I urge you
to do I urge you to take your kids your
grandkids to Kentucky Fried Chicken and
show them how to eat there safely
because they're gonna go with their
friends unique Kentucky roasted chicken
KRC you need their salad bar that's it
nothing else there is safe same with
mcDonald's I'm on the road a lot so I
eat a lot of McDonald's mileages have
their quarter pounder with some cheese
on it less tomatoes and onions because I
get it in eight minutes and it only cost
me three bucks if I go to Friday is the
same thing that caused me $18 right but
I don't eat the bun I don't eat the
mayonnaise I don't eat the salads I
don't need the dressing and all that
kind of stuff I just have my burger
which is 100% meat and then I put some
cheese on there and I put my lettuce
tomatoes onions of pickles now use
mustard that's all that is is mustard
seeds and vinegar and salt and water
nothing else in there okay and so you
can be very selective no fried foods I
do I do eat their little parfaits which
is a yogurt with two ounces of yogurt in
it it has four blueberries and a half of
strawberry I know because they do an
autopsy on them every time I eat them
this came out October 2012 just a
multiple just one multiple a day can
reduce your risk of cancer ones one
particular mineral we've known this
since 1957 one mineral actually went to
go it went back ash in 1912 one mineral
called selenium can reduce your risk of
breast cancer ladies about 82% if you
take 200 micrograms a day any any woman
who didn't have her OBGYN tell you to
take 200 micrograms of same every day
should be put in jail for mass murder
you also if you cook your meat
medium-rare instead of well-done you
reduce your risk of breast cancer ladies
it was University of South Carolina did
this study came out in 1998 reduce your
risk of breast cancer by four hundred
and sixty two percent I don't even know
what that means I know what 100% means
but what does 462 percent mean reduce
your risk of four hundred sixty two
percent of breast cancer if you eat your
meat cooked medium-rare rather than
well-done because a heterocyclic amines
and acrylamide that occur when you burn
me anybody own a dog anybody own a dog
I've already given you the statistics
we've tripled their lifespan with lemon
eight nine hundred diseases that we
still have and everybody knows you can't
give table scraps to a dog because it
messes up all the ratios in the food
you've got by food that you know I don't
know what it is about 50 60 cents a can
for a perfect perfect nutrition
biochemical nutrition and a triple their
lifespan you eliminate all these disease
the only time you take the dot or the
dog
you give him dog food the only time you
take him to the vet is once a year for a
rabies shot because that's the law he
have a dog for 25 years and unless
they're really clumsy and stupid and
chase cars get run over
other stuff like that you only have to
take your dog for 25 years once here to
the vet to get a rabies shot why do we
feed our kids their grandkids food that
we know will kill a dog so and I told
you earlier I started treating my
patients like dogs we came up with a 94
life program how long do you need to
take it for life I only need oxygen for
life how long you need water for life
how long do you need God for life how
long you need the 90 essential nutrients
for life who came up with a 90 essential
nutrients God okay the garden Eden was
perfect it had everything in it now
everybody can't go there's 7 billion
people on earth we can take the
information we already we actually
analyze a so that we know what's in the
Garden of Eden it was the first MapQuest
I don't even realize that first MapQuest
is in the Old Testament the Garden of
Eden was East of Eden there are 4 rivers
that dump into it right Keshawn pichon
the Tigris and Euphrates those rivers
are still dumping into the same place
that's still the Garden of Eden so I'm
going to show you what's in there
there's 90 essential nutrients they're
called essential nutrients ladies and
gentlemen for two reasons number one we
can't do without them you have to eat
them our supplement with them every day
because we can't make them we can't make
them also if you don't take them in you
get any one of them is missing it
horrible disease all which are fatal
some take longer to kill you in others
but they'll all kill you
it's efficiency diseases we need 60
minutes 2,000 90 essential nutrients or
mental so you know that minerals are
important as the dust the girl Lord made
us out of we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acid our food plants are grains
vessel fruits and nuts can take carbon
dioxide out of the air use the sun's
energy in a process known as
photosynthesis in the chlorophyll in the
green leaves to lop that Oh to off pump
it out in the atmosphere so we can
breathe it do you think that happened by
chance I don't think so I think there
was a overall plan for this okay so
you're right then the the the plant
takes two carbon atoms and makes long
carbon chains which become fatty acids
amino acids and vitamins
okay now nutritional minerals are not a
Kearny uniform Blanc around the cross
the earth nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocolate ice
cream because I used to ask my grandma
those people down the road where
hellions they all live to be a hundred
they never ate anything solid everything
they consumed his white lightening they
smoked they stayed up all night and
party loud music in here at three miles
away and a flat land in Missouri and
they live to be 100 the pastures would
add 42 and 48 and 50 why was that well
pasture just happened to live on a piece
of property they only had 12 minerals in
it and the Hellions living on a piece of
property that had 100 minnows just by
dumb luck the pasture can supplement
Kenny now honey can remember going your
grandma grandma's house and they had a
grandma Grandpa's house they had a wood
stove anybody remember the wood stove
day some of you may still have a wood
stove or fireplace what did everybody do
with the wood ashes every morning do
they throw them in the recycling bin to
save the earth where did the wood ashes
go in the garden they went in the garden
well what ashes are not ashes somebody
gave that name thousands of years ago
only kind of stuck affectionately but
that powder that's left in the stove and
the fireplace in the fire pit is
actually the minerals that the trees
sucked up out of the ground when you
burn the carbon in the wood the minerals
don't burn they just fall out as dust
well there's that word dust again okay
into the fireplace for the wood stove
over the fire pit then you take them up
and you throw them you broadcast them
out in the garden plant minerals aka
wood ashes and the okra and the sweet
potatoes the onions and the beans of the
peas and the squash and tomatoes and the
pumpkins the corn and whatever else
you're growing out there suck all those
minerals up and granddaddy did
supplement people my granddaddy would be
102 and he didn't supplement way as he
did he put those minerals into the
garden the trees or the the plants
sucked him up and he ate those plans
that he got his minerals in that fashion
he didn't have in a capsule but he took
those minerals okay that all ended the
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 we know the exact
moment cause of the front-page story in
every newspaper in the world the three
o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 it all ended this man
here on Pearl Street on the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
Brooklyn Bridge pulled the switch and
turned on the first commercial electric
generating plant within 10 years every
town in every city in the industrialized
world the first world country the rich
countries it converted from what is the
universal fuel to electricity propane
and natural gas now you tell me how many
wood ashes how many plant minerals are
left over in your home and you fuel it
with electricity propane natural gas
zero and what did you replace it with
nothing
and here comes a doctor strutting around
their white coat and her stethoscope
around her neck you don't need to take
them vitamins minerals oh just get
expensive your and waste your money you
can get everything you need just by
eating well you don't need to take them
vitamins and minerals they'll kill you
they're very dangerous you can overdose
in them vitamins minerals your buddy
okay you're the one with the white coats
oh I believe you
now this is a cornfield in central
Nebraska would you look at the
uniformity those rows uniformity the
plants I'm sure if you look at the ears
of corn they're all uniform - they're
the same genetic variety but I guarantee
you just by looking at that picture I
can tell you that there's enough
magnesium which makes the leaves green
just convert energy from the sunlight
there's enough phosphorous potassium to
drive growth in those fields because if
there wasn't you'd have bald spots or
thin spots you know table mouse know
those three minerals because all plant
needs to make good seeds for next
generation humans and all vertebrates or
their hummingbird a human or an elephant
needs 60 plants only need three do you
think farmers put in 60 no it's too
expensive you wouldn't pay for it and so
they only put in three because that's
all it takes to get the maximum meals
here's my favorite picture there's a
satellite picture from a hundred miles
up this is a Southern California
agricultural and this Pacific Ocean out
here this is a-you Humera zone over here
Mexico's down here 200 miles south of
this Salton Sea which is a small salt
lake about one-tenth the size of the
Great Salt Lake in Salt Lake City Utah
but why don't you see remember I told
you that nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocolate ice
cream this is what you're seeing here
all these different swirls and whirls
there are different veins of minerals
and mixtures and minerals different
amounts of each one so if you were to
grow tomatoes in every square foot
that's about a hundred square miles
because this picture is taken from a
hundred miles up when you grow tomatoes
and every square foot of that 100 square
miles down there could you guarantee
without supplementation the each tomato
was gonna give you the exact same amount
in variety of minerals no I mean you
don't have to know anything but you just
look at that picture you know that's not
the same well in the analyst tree we
know that and so in the amel industry we
put everything we know that that dog and
the cat and the chicken and the sheep
and the pig and the horse and turkey and
duck everything we're feeding with
pellets and mixtures of grains we put
everything we know they need in it when
you look at a label on the back of a can
of dog food or bag of dog food or bag of
chicken food or pig feed guess what the
only thing that shows up on that label
is what we put in there because if they
were to
analyze each batch yes what that can of
dog food cost you 500 bucks the only
thing that label represents is what we
put in there
everything else is was naturally in
there we consider that value-added and
see every morning when you wake up it's
the grace of God you woke up because the
night before when you ate dinner if you
didn't supplement with a 90s sense of
nutrients you don't know if you're gonna
die that night by missing one of those
that's how critical it is eating organic
doesn't matter organic says less
pollutants doesn't say anything about
the nutritional value of the food they
looked at 240 separate studies where
they looked at the amount of nutrition
minerals and vitamins in our gang clear
owned versus in organically grown grains
and vegetables and fruit and guess what
it depends on what role in the field are
growing in organic doesn't mean good
nutrition necessarily you still have to
supplement that's why vegans and
vegetarians died long before meteors let
me tell you the top 20 longevity
cultures on earth there's not a single
vegetarian in the group they're all
meteors they don't fry anything it's too
expensive to buy the oils they're poor
now this is the core of everything we do
we have a hundred cubic miles of this
stuff this is a compost it has 77
minerals in it it is totally pollutant
free that's the only place in America
that's totally pollutant free now that's
because the road that these guys are
standing on a 3000 foot elevation so if
the water would raise from the
underground aquifers the underground
rivers bring pollutants into this stuff
they'd be at the second flood ok you'd
be bad be like two-thirds of a mile deep
also this camp up here is 25 feet of
marine limestone we know that because
the animal and plant fossils are in
there are from the oceans so we know
there's been under the oceans for
thousands and thousands of years was
this from the flood I don't know but
certainly has been protected has 77
minerals in it it looks like coffee
grounds when you take a handful of it
and that's where we get our minerals
this is the core of everything we do
nobody else has access to this we have
25 different ways to get the 90
essential nutrients one of the more
convenient ones we call the healthy
start packet it has three products in it
has 245 nutrients in it including 115
fruits and vegetable juices 115 this is
not v8 this is V 115
as all 90 essential nutrients in optimal
amounts this is designed for perfect
nutrition for 100 pounds of human flesh
for a month so give this to a 50 pound
kid or a 50 pound [__] from Spain and
it doesn't matter 50 pounds goes by body
weight this this will be good for two
months if you give it to a hundred pound
person give or take 10 pounds that's a
month if you give it to a 200 pound
person give or take 10 pounds is for two
weeks you can give it to a 300 pound
person here or take 10 pounds or 20
pounds this is good for 10 days you have
to do it by body weight to get optimal
results okay I've been doing this twice
a day since I was 9 years old there's a
big story that you'll find in the book
dead doctors don't liar the CD dead
doctors know why okay my wife and I took
10 years and we read every one of the
720 issues of the National Geographic
they were published over a six-year
period we found the top 20 longevity
cultures on earth they have 25 common
threads we put all this information in
this book and I found it very
interesting invariably the top 20
longevity cultures they were all
extremely religious country cultures
that went to church every Sunday there's
not a pagan bunch in the top 20 I
thought that was really good stuff sorry
there's a whole chapter on that the
religious beliefs and how it helps you
reach a hundred any rate we put the top
five of these 25 common threads these
people have first of all you have five
generations living in the same household
conservation of effort they only have
one mortgage for five generations that
are five mortgages they have no need for
a hospice they have no need for daycare
they have no need for education
great-great-grandma teaches the girls
everything they need to know and
great-great-grandpa teaches the guys
everything they need to know so they
have no tax burden right they have no
doctors and no hospitals or clinics they
have no pharmacies or pharmaceuticals
they have no medicines
great-great-grandma is the medicine
woman the wise woman who treats
everybody with herbs and plasters and
soaks them in mud and mineral water and
whatever she does right and everyone in
every case a single doctor in any of
these places top 20 longevity cultures
it's not a single first world culture
you know a single rich nation of the top
20 longevity cultures and you have to
take note of this just from the National
Geographic they don't have any utilities
no roads no electricity no propane no
natural
so common fuel is wood oh and by dumb
luck by actual analysis of the soil by
the universities of the countries these
cultures come from to get the wood they
burned for fuel take the wood ashes from
that wood and put their gardens they
have all sixty essential minerals in a
Bachelor of dumb luck see it's not
genetic it's just dumb luck they all get
the 90 essential nutrients even though
they're from different ecosystems and
show you how they do that they come from
Islands and rain forests and deserts and
grassy plains they come from mountain
sides they come from all kinds of places
but yet they all get the 19th centuries
including the sixteen essential metals
from their wood ashes they have other
sources like glacial milk is a runoff
from glaciers a grind up the rocks and
things but they also put their wood
ashes and the wood they burned for fuel
grows on land that has more than 60
minerals in it they all live in a
calorie restricted diet how did you know
that calorie restriction will add years
to your life there is a science that
came out in the 1400s the first guy that
that wrote a book on it called the art
of living long was Luigi carneiro
there's a whole chapter devoted to him
and the calories trick to diet thing
I'll give you an example real quick this
works in every species of animal in
humans okay no doubt about it what let's
take a three pound male laboratory rat
and let's say heats two ounces a day of
ralston purina laboratory rat pellets
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take let's say
he'll live six years on that diet if you
do nothing to me just feed him he'll
live six years but if I take the
nutrition the vitamins minerals it's in
those two ounces of those laboratory rat
pellets put him in one ounce I've cut
the calories in half but I've doubled
nutrition per mouthful that rat will
live to be 12 years of age monkeys do it
cheap do it pigs do it dogs do humans do
it he wrote his first book called the
art of living long okay he'd love to be
a hundred and three when the doctor said
he wouldn't see his 33rd birthday he was
32 years old and he did it with a
calories triggered that and eating more
wood ashes now these people don't get
any bad stuff they don't eat fried foods
they don't get any processed meats with
nitrates and nitrites oh don't drink any
carbonated drinks not because they
wouldn't if that stuff was there but
who's gonna build drive throughs to sell
that kind of thing there's no roads no
cars I mean why would you build drive
throughs they're a bunch of guys on
Burroughs he can work okay so by default
by default they're getting their wood
ashes or minerals and by default
there there a poor they they only can
afford 900 calories a day these people
on the average taken 900 counties a day
Americans according to the New England
centenarian study which comes out every
year by Harvard Medical School age say
Americans taken 2830 200 calories every
day these people take in an average of
900 it's not because they know low
calories good farmers because they're
just poor they can lay four died their
gardens are as big as this table here
they're posted Sam Gardens now they do
get 20 times the fifty times the
antioxidants we do is actually measured
by or AK point Sorek is an acronym or
abbreviation for oxygen radical
absorbance capacity tells you how many
free radicals are neutralized by the
antioxidants and a food this is where
the super juices came from mangosteen
goji acai berry pomegranate juice
Patagonian wild blueberries New Zealand
Blanc currants and all these exotic
juices are very very good they have high
antioxidants but they're only 125th to
the recipe Americans taken 1500 points
1500 according to Harvard Medical School
these people take in 20,000 50,000
personally I take in a hundred thousand
every day I kind of hit it hard now this
was the last Nashes year Africa red oh
yeah it's May of 2013
look at that this baby will live be 120
and when you read it you read my book
immortality you'll see that they read in
March allottee because every point they
make is taking chapter by chapter and I
love it it's great because in the
Western Hemisphere the long said people
in the Western Hemisphere are the decoy
ins from the clan Peninsula and Costa
Rica Central America you live out in the
forest you're uneducated your average
lifespan is 90 you have 40 times 100
olds we do they have 100 for 250 their
population we have 100 per 10,000 they
have 40 times 100 although they don't
have doctors and I have clinics I don't
have household no private government
surance they have grandma on great
grandma on great-great grandma what they
got and they have by dumb luck minerals
because they're taking their wood ashes
and putting in their gardens this child
from Central America is not from black
Africa not from white Europe or not from
yellow Asia this baby is kind of an
Indian from Central America these people
live to be 90
and when they wrote this article is
really is just beautiful because the
last couple of paragraphs they say well
his drop-dead ridiculous gravity these
kids will live to be 120 they're just
living longer and longer longer they're
already living now to be 105 they're
gonna live me 120 and we can't tell if
it's genetics or dumb luck it's dumb
luck because they chose to live there
thousands of years ago they couldn't
find the gene because there ain't none
as they say okay let's look at
billionaires if money meant something
for health and longevity billionaires
should be as a group they should
percentage-wise not numbers obviously
but percentage-wise
they should have the highest average
lifespan compared to any other
demographic in America and they should
have more hundred rolls if money and
power and you know it you know knowing
how to get things would help you I'd ask
him that for many many years actually
had a CD that I came out with what kills
billionaires look what they called their
article because I kept telling him and
calling him and call him and they said
no no no no no in 2004 they did their
own survey they found that billionaires
are killed by the same unglamorous
things to kill everybody else heart
attack stroke diabetes obesity cancer
suicide because heat the same stupid
things we do in 2004 there's never been
in there had never been a billionaire
live to be 100 the average lifespan of
78 there his lifespan but falling down
red wine drunk in Charlotte North
Carolina living on the bridge at 75 they
dumpster dive in the you know and the
dumpsters behind McDonald's and live
under the bridge and they lived to be 75
many of them live to be 100 that's
because they don't go to doctors and get
killed
well the the billionaire's didn't like
that report and so they said look we
want you to redo that so
Forbes magazine did again seven years
later they redid it and came out in
March of 2011 remember the first one was
2004 they said as a march of 2011
there's still not been a billionaire
living to be 100 all the statistics from
all the things they looked at in 2004
were exactly the same statistically
except one one of these subjects was
dramatically different that was the
average life span one did change
dramatically there was life span in 19
hours Hume in 2004 it was 78 in 2011 66
it dropped 12 years that's statistically
impossible
in seven years to drop 12 years ain't
happenin okay that was driven I mean I
can see him losing a week you can seem
losing a month or something like that
but in seven years time they're not
gonna lose 12 years how did that happen
so I treat a lot of billionaires they
come to me with terminal diseases are
told her inoperable have less a year to
live less than six months to live and I
kill him and so I have this big
entourage of billionaires who follow
what we do they they love the
ninety-four life they got their whole
families on and so on I call them up and
they say look I need ten of you to ask
ten or fifteen or twenty of your
billionaire buddies and your country
clubs one question for me oh yeah well
and it Wallach anything I want you to
ask him if they've done anything
proactive it they've done anything
different since that reverse report came
out from Forbes in 2004 they said none
of them living 100 they only live be an
average of 78 did they do anything
special
call me back a week later said well that
was very perceptible I like you on the
average every billionaire spent a half a
million dollars five hundred thousand
dollars building fitness centers in
their house and their workplaces in
their offices and they got these
computers or voice-activated they could
be rolling for three hours and given the
instructions for their businesses and
listening to reports and everything from
this computer exercise is the most
dangerous thing you can voluntarily and
get involved with you do it were
incorrectly will kill more people of
anything else I'm going to tell you more
details in minutes so bear with me
you've got to do a little bit more
before I get to that piece so just
remember that exercise is dangerous
Steve Jobs died ten years before the
average billionaire smart no doubt about
that lots of money no doubt about that
but he was a nun supplemented vegan he
hired a five-star vegan chef to cook
everything from him they've spent lots
of money flew in organic food from
everywhere they stir-fried it an organic
extra extra extra virgin virgin virgin
olive oil and coconut oil and then when
he got his pancreatic cancer which is
predictable because all those
heterocyclic amines and acrylamide and
trans fatty acids from the heated oils
he went to the most well-respected most
highly regarded most published the most
funded
cancer research doctor in America he was
dead he died he's sure that doctor shot
him in the head
he should have gone to Costa Rica and
find the oldest person there say I want
you to feed me like you're eaten
here's some extra money give me what
you're eating and he'd still be alive
today
exercise exercise is a very very
dangerous enterprise the average
lifespan when you take all professional
athletes together all sports you add
them together the average lifespan
professional athlete is 62 you take the
average lifespan of a professional
football player you take out all the
suicides is 51 there has never been with
the exception of three black guys from
the old Negro baseball league days back
in the 1920s there has never been a
professional athlete ever live to be 100
if exercise is so good how come they
don't live to be 100 they get paid their
only job is to stay healthy that's the
only job when they get paid three
million dollars a game their whole
responsibility is eat right supplement
right exercise right sleep avoid all the
bad stuff that's all they're getting
paid for is to stay healthy and perform
you have whole seasons off they still
get paid every month it was wild when
you think about it in their average
lifespan is 62 and none of them live to
be 100 well why is that
that's because when you exercise you
sweat don't you and people love you and
you're sweating in your job you're
working in factories 120 degrees in the
factory you throw them bales of hay
whatever your work is your roofing in
the summer time you know next time so it
said take plenty of what that's what
kills you because here's why that's the
obvious question why because sweat is
not water sweat is a soup that contains
all the nutrients in your blood let's
say you're eating 6572 nutrients you
haven't quite gotten to the 90 yet the
same principle is true for 90 but the
average person isn't taking the 90 yet
so let's say they're getting 65 to 72
nutrients in their food and they're
sweating out 65 to 72 nutrients so here
you are let's say this is your
nutritional reserves your BA and you're
sweating and you're drinking water
what's him and your nutritional reserves
that's kinda like replacing a cuarto
well every time your engine burns a
quarter all with a quart of water how
much you do that by the sixth week
though your engine wouldn't be very
happy with it so now let's see here you
started getting break down your ACL
ligament you started getting to break
down your cartilage you start getting
muscle cramps so I can't lose teeth
pilot pressure diabetes start gaining
some weight oh now you got fibromyalgia
now you got
and I have a heart attack which you may
or may not survive from shame on all the
fitness guys actually I have to tell you
this quick story I was called to Atlanta
oh there's got to be 12 years ago and
this was to an LA fitness center well
the manager is one of our associates one
of our distributors and he said doc I
got this whole new crop of people here
they've never heard of it I want you to
give a half hour lecture just on the
just on the sports piece okay doesn't
had to be the whole thing is on the
sports things okay
so I get there and there's a group about
this size couple hundred people in there
and showing my slides on athletes and
this beautiful girl she had to be 32
years old I mean she's drop-dead
gorgeous and she's in a thousand dollars
silk to two you know and all this stuff
and she goes oh dr. Wallach and she gets
stands up and she's facing the audience
right in front of me
so dr. Wallach is not vitamins minerals
it's aerobics and exercise she goes it's
a aerobic and exercise it's aerobics and
exercise she goes and half the people in
there 100 of them were her customers her
clients so they all get behind it all
conga dancing out it's all exercising
aerobics it's all exercising roads
it was the most disastrous meeting I've
ever had in my life I was mortified well
three weeks later I get started getting
hundreds of calls from LA we need this
stuff we need your 90 solution we need
your sports drink which we call rebound
has a hundred nutrients in a Gatorade
has two sir eighty-eight chart with
Gatorade swimmy
I said why am I getting all these calls
from Atlanta Georgia wanting this stuff
remember that galley just rub your meals
well how could I forget it whereas
meeting ever had last week thirty years
old she's on the treadmill at lunchtime
thousand people in there I'll watch our
sheet boy she's doing her thing gorgeous
she drops dead of a heart attack right
there BAM and everybody in that center
called me and got on this stuff it was a
very expensive way but you know she
advertised Burmese oh I love her now the
journal American Medical Association
1982 the journal the American Medical
Association 1982 while running a man's
risk a heart attack death increases by a
factor of seven hundred percent because
it's all honey be sure you drink plenty
of water got there sweating out your 60
to 70 nutrients you're just replacing
with water you're gonna die you're gonna
break down you can't run an engine on
six quarts of water what it should be
six quarts of oil is that simple this
fella here ran 100 marathons Brian
Maxwell is one of the top athletes in
Canada
is considered a fitness guru hardtack
claims another fitness guru died was a
51 of a heart attack from actually the
heart attack he died from was a simple
deficiency of a single mineral I've
actually done 1700 autopsies on people
that died of that one type of heart
attack I'm an expert at it not because
I'm bragging it says nobody else has
done 1700 autopsies on people that die
to that thing and so he actually ran 100
marathons never came in less than fifth
had 14 gold medals three the Olympics 11
were in the the Iron Men things World
Games and the triathlons this guy was as
fit as a human being Kabini dies at 51
of a heart attack because he sweat out
all his minerals just drank water in his
book you read his book Jim Fixx the
first guy showed you that orange book
you look in the index under vitamins and
minerals it says go to page 165 you go
to page 105 it says don't take vitamins
minerals you get everything eat food
just run you live longer and thousands
and thousands and thousands and millions
of people listen to him why would you
follow somebody's advice who died at 51
and 52 doing what they're telling you to
do if you've lived 150 I'd do it right
but died at 51 52 it's not a very good
recommendation
this guy here collapsed during a playoff
game Reggie Lewis collapsed on a playoff
game with the Charlotte Hornets back in
1993 28 years old captain of the Boston
Celtics good-looking young fella great
captain he never jumped in the stands
and beat up the paying customers and
stuff like that he was a great field
leader on the court he was a great man
on the street he's just a good man 28
years old and he collapses with a
cardiomyopathy heart attack a symbol
deficiency of a single mineral called
selenium and he didn't die was taken to
the hospital neighbor able to keep him
alive so the Celtics got a team of 12 at
the top cardiologist from around the
world and while they're arguing amongst
themselves who's going to be the head
cardiologist to determine whether he got
a heart transplant or what they're gonna
do with him and if they did a heart
transmitted he'd be the first
professional athlete to get back and
play with a heart transplant so they're
kind of excited about that he dies of a
second card he might be a heart attack
two weeks later cuz nobody gave him
fifty cents worth of selenium well here
comes the real story this is the story
that I want to get to but I had to
precede it with that story the guy who
was gonna be the head of that dream team
of Cardiology who's gonna take care of
Reggie Lewis was a guy by the name of
dr. W Thomas no so who's the head of the
cardiology department of Harvard Medical
School
he ran the Boston Marathon 20 times
himself he was the cardiologist for the
NBA
he's a cardiologist for the Celtics he
taught cardiology in the medical school
of course but it also taught it's eme
continued medical education stuff for
doctors and nurses when this guy was
considered the cardiologist of all
cardiologist well year-and-a-half after
Reggie died of that selenium deficiency
occurring about the heart attack
dr. Nessa dies are the same thing at age
48 now if I was his family I'd be
embarrassed to tears saying what a
wonderful cardiologist says he dies of a
heart attack at age 48 he was dumb and
dead he was dumb and dead
this guy may have been able to take your
heart out and not lose a drop of blood
and put it into him he may have been a
good seamstress but he didn't know
anything about hearts cuz he died of a
heart attack and I thought it was kind
of just as he died in a town in
Massachusetts called Dedham I mean that
should be on his tombstone died in
Dedham now I don't have a doctor I told
you I am in to a doctor in 65 years the
only piece of paper my truly the only
piece of paper my health record there's
one piece of papers my birth certificate
there's nothing else in there I'm 74
years old everybody in America be the
same way just think about it just think
how humble the medical system would be
if everybody in America would like me
medically only go to doctor once every
74 years they'd be real humble wouldn't
they please please I'll be alone anymore
so let's say just for theory he was my
cardiologist he said okay Wallach you're
74 years old now you got to watch your
blood pressure once you give up salt
well if he said that to me and I knew
what his future was gonna be I would go
around and I would get every salt shaker
and Charlotte I'd leave a buck so they
didn't think I'm stealing him I build a
two-foot frame around my bed and i fill
that frame you know celtic salt celtic
salt Himalayan salt sea salt Morton's
salt every kind of salt pink salt yellow
salt brown salt everything you can think
oh and I get naked every night at will
around till I'm sleeping in a cocoon of
salt every night
he said that eggs were bad for it
because the cholesterol I'd eat 25 a day
if he said that exercise was good fry
yeah
I'd lay on that bed of salt eating my
eggs and I wouldn't even blink because I
wouldn't want to be like him at age 48
dad dad dad now following his advice
this is what happens is the gal hero
Nelda pierce 19 years old was chased by
every professional woman's basketball
team in the world she was 6 foot 5 could
do the Air Jordan thing she's just a
lovely girl and she chose to say look
I'm gonna take two years of academic
service I'm gonna go to Florida State
make a long story short halfway
through her freshman year she drops dead
during a game at age 19 from a ruptured
aneurysm which is caused by deficiency
of a single mineral copper she drinking
Gatorade go look and try and find any
copper in Gatorade
there's no copper in Gator there was a
selenium in Gatorade they killed that
girl as soon as they shot her and then
they have the gall to say that she died
of a genetic disease she died of a
simple copper deficiency she taken a 90
she'd still be alive today
Wes Leonard there's a playoff at
sudden-death playoff in Western Michigan
for a semi final game make a long story
short he catches the tip-off he runs
across the court slam dunks and his team
wins southern death 54 to 52 this is him
just seconds after he makes those points
his teammates lift him up three seconds
after this picture was taken he drops
dead of a cardiomyopathy a heart attack
aged 16 now the medical examiner had a
moment here this is a meta this is a
national story the medical examiner had
a moment he they got his name spelt
right medical examiner David starch said
the stress Leonard placed on his heart
through athletics could have played
those days and wiggle words could have
played a role but his death could not be
easily explained his explain is a
deficiency of selenium caused by
sweating and drinking water or Gatorade
and he had a chance to save every kid in
America there because everybody read
that story that man should go to jail
forever when he dies of natural causes
his body should be fed to a rabid dog
that's the meanest thing I can think of
what doctors want to do as a result of
it Wes Leonard dying let's do more EKGs
yes I could do anything for nutritional
deficiency it doesn't show up on an EKG
this girl la dropped dead caught him up
with you heart attack she's she was a
cheerleader girl sweat they need the 90
essential nutrients too especially if
you know they're gonna grow up and have
babies
she died 16 years old somebody needs to
go to jail make a long story short we
get on with the next couple of subjects
we'll move on to the diseases Theo
Ratliff just retired from the NBA 14
years his career was over 14 years ago
he had bone to bone arthritis in both
knees had cartilage pop off his hip he
caught a pass her in a game fractured
his wrist the orthopedic surgeons at the
Atlanta Hawks wouldn't sign off on him
so his career was over and we rebuilt
him using her healthy bone and joint
pack and we actually made the rebound
sport
string for him he has a hundred
nutrients in it including selenium and
copper and everything else you need has
100 nutrients in it and he played for 14
more years after the Arth peak surgeon
said he wouldn't play he made 140
million dollars after they said his true
was over now do you think his wife
Christina doesn't love me now next to
Theo now she's six-foot-five herself so
every time I go over there she kind of
hugs me around the head and Pat's on my
head she's so sweet
rebound you have somebody you love who's
sweatin whether it's work or play or
sports of any age you give them rebound
don't give them Gatorade you'll add 25
years to life and they won't drop dead
who needs doctors this came out to
February 2005 special health issue to
you as news will report your future
position might not be a medical doctor
you may be better off in 1993 I said the
average medical doctor which is done by
looking at 200 [__] raised of primary
care physicians adding up the age of
death divided by 200 got 58 why would
you go to a group of people whose
average lifespan is 58 to learn how it
would be once money is God commanded
they didn't like that so they did their
own say they said well Wallach lied
there was primary care physician family
doctor doesn't little b-58 like he says
we lived to be 56 why were they so eager
to publish that well that's because they
were more interested in showing my
statistics were incorrect and it did
show that they were showing that they
died two years earlier so I will
apologize for giving him two too many
years I want to make a prediction here
copper deficiency causes white hair and
drie yucky looking skin he's a classic
example of a copper deficiency aneurysms
here a Arda aneurysms so if anybody has
connection with him you need to let him
know he's in trouble it may make you
look professor I'll remember Albert
Einstein died at 64 ruptured aneurysm he
had white hair just like that okay now
the last one in this section is my
favorite obituary and then I'll get to
these diseases real quick George Francis
oldest man an American he died 112 in
December 2008
this is daughter mean the newspaper to
him cuz he was illiterate he lived out
in the swamps Louisiana didn't have any
electricity coming out there propane or
natural gas
he used wood for fuel and he lived
through 19 US presidents all of whom the
average lifespan is 75 if they only had
they had won at least one university
degree unless here lower than they had
to
and presidents are cared for not by dumb
country doctors but by very very
well-respected medical guys right but
their aims lies men's 56 exactly half a
Jorge's age when he died he's a black
man and when he died at age 112 the
reporters asked his daughter what did
your daddy do to live to be 112 and she
said he broke all the rules of healthy
eating who came up with the rules of
healthy medical doctors who lived to be
56 according to her own study she went
on and she said he broke all the rules
of health eating with a diet heavy on
dairy eggs and large sandwiches pig fat
cholesterol and saturated fat I'm going
with George because he eats exactly like
all those long live top 20 longevity
cultures once you appreciate that the
game changes now you can't eat fried
foods you didn't need fried foods
everything was steamed and boiled he ate
like a Cajun okay now we got six
diseases to cover real quick and then
I'm done so weird look at six diseases
obviously we're number one obesity as we
got to talk about obese I promise you I
would teach you and prove to you it's as
simple mineral deficiencies okay this
was predicted following their directions
they can't be right
so I keep listening if you just do
nothing you'll be better off than listen
to him just a reminder that's what
you're gonna get if you don't change
what you're doing don't wait for doctors
don't wait for the government cuz they
ain't changing according to experts 70%
of our kids under the age of 12 or over
weights 40% of our kids under the age of
12 or obese meaning 30 pounds or more of
their ideal weight it has nothing to do
with too much screen time it has nothing
to do it to a lack of exercise or eating
too much has nothing to with any of
those it's a simple nutritional
deficiencies this is my favorite charts
for adult people who are obese up until
we were never above 12% obese it was
like 10 12 11 8 9 12 8 9 12 kind of
thing kind of like a stock market but in
82 jumped up to fifteen twenty years
later doubled 12 years later 2012 went
up to 42% just came out in 2006 I got to
move all this over and put a red bar in
here show that I put the bar in there as
42 percent now so what happened here Liz
when everything went wrong doctors said
eat more whole grains give up fat
because carbohydrates and grains only
have four point five calories per gram
and
have nine Calabrian double the calories
but here's the problem you eat a quarter
of a stick of butter you won't be hungry
all day
you mean a bowl of cereal for breakfast
a half hour later you're hungry and you
eat again
and then you get hungry and eat again so
you're eating 24 times a day when you're
eating carbohydrates do we fatten cattle
on cream and butter and eggs no a
phantom on whole grains Oh what what we
fatten cattle and whole grains you're
told to eat whole grains you're fat look
well there you go
this is not difficult if they were
correct for the past 50 years the chart
should look like that shouldn't it but
instead this is what you got
just like those seed if bacteria and
hospitals calling the doctors directions
is what you get this is what you get
this is my favorite now I deal a lot
with people who weigh 400 600 800 pounds
in that range that has been what I deal
with this woman was not my patient but
she could have been my page because I
deal with a lot with people like her but
she had to get astre Booker records when
it came to weight she's a heaviest woman
ever weighed they'd gives Mirrabooka
records would not believe her weight so
they sent their own technicians and they
had a big flatbed truck come out with
their own scales that they had
calibrated and she weighed 1242 pounds
in the seven-year period between 1987
1994 she lost 736 pounds after a gastric
bypass and restricting her her calories
down 2,000 calories a day and then she
died because fat is not the disease fat
fat is the symptom of the disease just
like high blood sugar is not the disease
when you have diabetes is a symptom of
the disease you can control your blood
sugar you're still gonna die from
diabetes you control your fat you're
still gonna die from obesity even though
you lost some weight because it's not
the fent it's just a symptom stop doing
what they tell you stop and save
yourselves okay here's the first real
clue this is not a rare condition this
happens a million times a day how many
of you ladies when you're pregnant had
cravings that's because the embryo is
stealing nutrients from her faster than
she's taken a min as the nutrition
deficiencies that make her eat and eat
and eat and eat okay his choices of what
she eats
I mean grandma you didn't him with
ruffles with ridges and Lay's potato
chips you just can't eat one grandma
only had wood ashes and clay out in the
backyard and so what was she she ate
clay out in the backyard and what
Asha's when she had those cravings
there's no calories in wood ashes in
clay this gal loved lightbulb she was a
big story in Good Morning America in
March of 2011 she loves wood paper
products cardboard stick sheets rocks
dirt she loves diet coke cans not
classic coke cans backhoe cams she's the
magnets out of shower curtain she loves
plastic bottles and toys maybe that's
why they took the toys out of the Happy
Meal I don't know so my wife and I came
up with another book I told you about
this one in Hell's Kitchen and the
subtitle is the Claus French to cure
obesity it also talks about type 2
diabetes and the metabolic syndrome
which are really all the same disease
these are all the same disease just
different sort of stages of it it's a
cause it's not me that's Alfred
Hitchcock by the way okay
this book gives you all the facts now
here it comes
Loyola University Chicago Medical School
exercise won't cure obesity I mean they
were assaulted by everybody even Chuck
Norris who sells all those exercise
machine TV I mean everybody went after
them but when they reviewed their daddy
said by golly they're right exercise
will actually make you heavier if you're
not supplementing properly so eight
months later when it was proved to the
satisfaction of Time magazine was a
cover article August 2009 myth without
exercise it won't make you lose weight
because if you're sweating you're
thinking about that high burned 150
calories in the gym today so I'm going
to Starbucks and I'm going to have an
800 calories stressful latte mocha mocha
doko Lokesh mocha now here is another
clue
anybody who ever worked with horses okay
what are you calling a hard cheese on
the fence her being very good how do you
get rid of cribbing other than shooting
a horse and a head
you give him minerals you given bone
meal give them trays no salt block
within three to five days they stop
cribbing so in 1978 the first clinic I
bought was a weight loss clinic and make
a long story short people would come in
every month they renew their
prescriptions for thyroid they renew the
prescription or drugs suppress her
appetite but they never gained any
weight never lost anyway they just
stayed the same there's still 50 100
pound 200 pounds overweight so I said
you know they're reminding me of a horse
that's cribbing so I began to give them
minerals and I started losing two pounds
a day this is what a horse looks like
when they're cribbing the horse isn't
even there this is in a horse and buggy
Amish farm barn south of Fort Wayne
Indiana I was there to see some mustard
history kids but they were late the
buggies were late so I went into the
barn be my veterinary self and I saw
this very typical of creepy were the
hardest cribbing along that thing to
cribben on the corners they're reaching
over cribbing over there okay they're
reaching up and cribbing along that beam
so cribbing is munchies munchies
cribbing and cribbing munchies motion
cribbing so if you have cravings and you
take our 94 live program according to
body weight one unit per 100 pounds of
body weight per month you to use the
rebound instead of two liters of Pepsi a
day our monster our Gatorade guess what
he'll lose weight so start losing a half
a pound a pound a day you want to go
faster we do have a meal replace on FX
weight management system only has 110
calories per meal I make it with water I
like to throw in a couple of eggs it
gets up to about 250 calories with the
eggs and that helps you because then
you're only going to have three or two
of those a day plus a salad you're cool
but well I like to throw them we call
ASAP as soon as possible as soon as
possible as drops you put on your tongue
we've absorbed on your tongue and so you
do one of those bottles per month you
need to lose 50 pounds or less you need
to lose 51 pounds or more you take two
bottles a month but two drivers fall
under your tongue now give you a couple
of examples this is Jerry he had a bread
belly wasn't a drinker but a beer belly
then you had a bread belly because his
wife Judy loved to make bread he was on
our 90 essential nutrients and but he
didn't gain any weight other than his
belly just he had a bread belly and you
have to appreciate bread bellies and
beer bellies are the same thing because
bread and beer is made from the same
stuff they're both made from yeast and
wheat and barley round oats the only
difference is one is fermented and the
other was baked is the same ingredient
so you can understand they get a bread
Bell in your beer building Mary oh you
added his system for 45 days was the
ASAP
he lost his red belly and in 45 days
okay well it's 52 pounds now ladies just
to show that women can lose weight too
there's a little brandy and she's 5 foot
2 in this picture she weighed 158 pounds
and her she had had three kids and she
started drinking two these two-liter
bottles of Pepsi during her present for
a first pregnant she gained 58 pound
because she weighed a hundred pounds
when she first got pregnant and she
gained 58 pounds
she got 50 pounds of fat okay one third
of her body weight her
husband affectionately called her his
chunky-monkey that's where I got the
term and she hated that so when when
rebound came up she started drinking
rebound and she lost 20 pounds is
drinking rebound to the Pepsi I mean
within a month she lost but 21 day 20
min a month she lost 20 pounds she we
put her on the the ASAP and she lost
another 38 pounds now she's back down to
a hundred pounds now I suspect there's
be more kids in that family okay let's
talk about alzheimers disease was
actually four different dimensions that
Americans commonly get number one the
most common one that actually has vast
your dementia the same thing that causes
a blocking the arteries in your heart
block the arteries in your brain it's
called vascular dementia and you don't
get enough oxygen and food to your brain
there's nothing wrong with your brain
there's enough option and food going in
there start forgetting things and it's
called basilar dementia and then there's
Korsakoff syndrome which is a deficiency
of a single vitamin this was discovered
in the late 1700s by a Japanese naval
surgeon and so we always prepare for
that one there's a warning key Korsakoff
is the same deficiency that one vitamin
plus ms/ms a multiple sclerosis mixed in
with it and then there's Allison disease
I've seen people with all four
dimensions Allis numbers tidal wave is
fear that's cuz there's 80 million baby
boomers come along this came out in 2009
Alzheimers in a relentless upward
trajectory it's kind of like that
obesity chart right and also the it is
the Alzheimer's chart numbers look
particularly grim for baby boomers
because they're on egg beaters egg white
omelets boneless skinless chicken breast
and the worst possible thing is they
took the statin drugs to lower their
cholesterol
talk about a perfect storm for making
Al's her disease again reminder realize
in the same sentence only a doctor could
do that Alzheimers is the only disease
among the top six killers in the USA for
which there's no prevention cure
treatment that's all a lie
okay 1992 the University of California
San Diego and the Salk Institute came
out with this study and they said if you
take somebody that van Salazar Azeez you
give a high dose of vitamin E they'll
get better
now this isn't some comic book stuff
this is a ten year study from the Salk
Institute and the University of
California San Diego school so yeah I
read this into my audio cassette tape
this is part of my own new cassette tape
I said vitamin e candies memory loss
I was victims which means it cannot be
genetic because there's no genetic
disease that you can even help any
little bit by giving a vitamin or
mineral so it if you can get some
clinical improvement by giving them one
vitamin that ain't genetic simple stuff
that's fourth grade biology every
Medical Association you know in every
state United States went to their State
Attorney General's and had them send me
Adam and Warren make me prove what I was
saying was true otherwise they're gonna
take my assets away and put me in jail I
don't know how they put me jail in 50
states but cut me up I guess and so we
had to send all 50 states a certified
copy of that newspaper plus a copy of
the CD but they could see I was just
reading them so that's the First
Amendment thing so all states except
Arizona and Michigan dropped the charges
I had to go do kind of a pre-trial
hearing and everything then Michigan and
Arizona but the judge threw it out after
they saw my presentation everything and
so they had to pay my legal fees and
transportation and I love that part okay
then in 2010 front cover story US News
report America's best nursing homes
aging well obviously marketing to the
baby boomers what science reveals about
aging is your job killing you their
first baby boomers heart battle but this
is why I bought it seven habits that
lower the risk of Alastor disease what
does that tell you it ain't genetic if
you can sleep two more hours a night if
you can walk around the block two more
times if you need a banana every week
that you weren't doing you can read a
little bit more read a book every month
there's one other thing they mentioned
was read a book every month reduce risk
of bowel disease at eight genetic so
right there it says you have an eight
genetic and you get it late in life that
means we can prevent it and that means
we can get rid of it
amen remember there's four different
dimensions so I was like to treat for
all four well ten years after that first
study I showed you the vitamin E Johns
Hopkins released a study that they did
in cash counted at CA CH e not see a sh
but see a CH e Valley area Utah and this
is the bottom of a small sea or lake
thousands and thousands years ago and
the mountains go all the way around it
this is laser flat they didn't have that
bulldozer flex was just bottom Lakers
Inland Sea so it's just flat 200 feet of
topsoil in there and there's no
restaurants I mean these are very very
religious Mormons that live in there
they're all from a Scottish back
crowd everybody who moved into that
Valley came from Scotland for some
reason they all converted to Mormonism
and they lived in ate and they're all
farmers and they all ate the food they
wouldn't even go to a restaurant they're
very religious people they're kind of
like the equivalent to the Mormons of
the Jewish kosher people are to the
Jewish people okay
the Orthodox Jewish people and they have
a supplemental book to their holy book
okay and this holy book supplement tells
them what to eat what not to eat just
like the kosher Jewish people are that
actually people have their stuff they're
not supposed to eat they're supposed to
stuff they're supposed to eat sorry
that's what they did here whole Johns
Hopkins how many heard of Johns Hopkins
Baltimore mer I'm very famous medical
school they sent a whole team of guys
out there they found 5,000 people in
that Valley over the age of 65 they
divided him in half and they gave half
of them 2,500 for ten years a vitamin
supplement the other half a gave a dummy
pill double-blind randomized study gold
study from one of the top medical
schools in America they published it in
2004 and I'll bet your doctor didn't
email you the results if he didn't you
need to fire him I guarantee most of it
be firing your doctors the first study
in 1992 is just vitamin E I was so
excited about that I need to him all 90
but instead they just added vitamin C to
it we don't wanna get too aggressive
here so he just had a vitamin C make a
long story short they said people taking
the vitamin C any over the 10 years were
78 percent less likely to have a
diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease in them
that didn't 70 percent reduction in risk
by just adding two vitamins to their
diet now I guarantee it's more
complicating that because right now as
we speak I'm having in fact I'm gonna be
meeting with these guys here in a couple
of weeks they've been doing an analysis
of the solve for me in that Valley
because those two vitamins are a
cofactor for some mineral or minerals in
there right now I'm giving everybody
everything so I know they're getting it
all because they're getting everything
right but I guarantee there's some
minerals in there that are very high but
any rate if you take everything you're
gonna get everything right but just
think about you can reduce your risk now
by 78% just with supplementation same
people they're homogeneous
same cultural background they're all
from Scotland they're all farmers they
all live in the same Valley there all
the same religion they all eat the same
things all avoid the same thing he's
like laboratory rats they were about as
homogeneous as you can get why didn't
why did medical school go there why did
they go there because you can't in
Baltimore Maryland you can't find two
people who are like let alone 5,000 it
was pretty smart on their part with it
so anytime your doctor says it's genetic
and there's no way to prevent her cures
in there why are pants on fire
okay well four years ago I believe it
was hip sister he's from Greensboro and
she was from Charlotte and she's one of
her associates one of our distributors
and she called me four years ago and
said my brother was diagnosed eight
years before she called me and said
which is 12 years ago now and said he
was diagnosed with Allison disease and
the doctor says genetic and I might as
well get my reservation in his nursing
home right now so I'm be sure to have a
space the time came blah blah blah
and scaring me and then so I've took him
to neurological clinics I even went to
the medical school here in North
Carolina and had the head of the
department neurology examined him and he
agreed with a primary care physician
that was al-azhar disease and when she
called me four years ago he had lost his
memory complete he's unable to
communicate with grunts her barks her
blinks or raising a finger anything he
could not communicate anyway we couldn't
tell if he was I never saw him this is
over the phone he would lay on the floor
and curl up in a field position very
what I did for him was this it was say
okay look I'm gonna treat him for all
four dimensions because we're kind of
late in the game here right I said well
thank you for calling me in early on the
case right he's in a hospice he's being
fed with the g-tube so you got to get
him off the ensure because it sure has
made sixty percent by volume corn oil
trans fatty acids the worst possible
thing for normal brain let alone anybody
with any brain disease like parties
these MS Lou Gehrig's disease range in
two matches know ensure
fill cage we need you to get your
brother off of ensure we have in that
shake we told you about the slender
effects but if we just make it with
water you lose weight and what I want
you to do is make it with a heavy
whipping cream because I'm gonna rebuild
his reign
maybe with heavy whipping cream won't
you put four eggs in it I want him to
have two servings of that a day through
his g-tube
have to whip it up real fine go through
the g-tube and then I want him to have
four more exam I have a total of twelve
eggs a day because I'm calculating how
much cholesterol I'm giving them
rebuild the brain in case he does have
Allison disease right not cooked but
wrong then I wanted to have two healthy
heart and brain packs per month but I
want him to have four half doses a day
split out during the day mix it with
milk get it through the G tube that's
how you get the other four eggs in there
then in case it's mastered to Metro I'm
going to take three of the ultimate
daily tablets three times a day grind
them up put them in with that milk and
the other stuff and put them through the
G tube because it actually dilates
arteries and and improves blood flow
they don't him to take three of our D
stress capsules three times a day that's
three bottles a month because it has
that one vitamin is deficient when you
have Korsakoff syndrome and wernicke
Korsakoff syndrome he he got 28,000
times the minimum daily requirement of
that one they don't have selenium on
they have nine more selenium a day trip
breakfast Vita lunch for you know three
bottles a month in case he has wernicki
course cost could I get rid of the
plaque in his brain from the MS then I
need him to take 12 of our smart FX a
day these are DHA zan DPS which are the
raw materials for the brain to make
neurotransmitters for memory and
cognition problem-solving and memory I'm
gonna have 12 of those a day he had to
puncture a little soft gel capsule to
squeeze that and through the g-tube she
took a six-month leave of absence
because the technicians and the doctors
at the hospice wasn't do it should
how many give him the best shot I can
I'm gonna take six months off of work
and do it now she calls me a week later
I told her call me every two weeks and
give me kind of a progress report
because this is an under controlled
situation she personally would do it
every day so I had face she was gonna do
it so she calls me on the radio the
producer says doc there was this lady
screaming about her brother with Alison
Rosie's well it's a week maybe something
terrible was happening put her on I'm
gonna quote her exactly so bear with me
it's very emotional for me because I
want to quote for you okay here we go so
be prepared and she said to me quoting
her now he's in one week's time he got
dressed and walked out did not have
Alzheimer's disease
Alice Herbert's easy take me nine to 12
months to reverse but he had Korsakoff
syndrome which is curable in a week it's
a simple deficiency of a single by and
remember I told you I gave him 28,000
times a minimum daily requirement that
vitamin because she gave me little
signals to make me think was more likely
a course called syndrome in Alexandra
disease so I kind of hedged bet on that
one
and it worked I do this a thousand times
a year now very simple it's called
Korsakoff syndrome the same formula
whereas for parkas 'yes Ms Lou Gehrig's
disease I have many many wealthy
I mean billionaires that we've reversed
their terminal Parkinson's disease in
three months he went from being weeks
away from death to three months later
perfectly normal okay partner disease
same formula okay arthritis 95% of
arthritis is a simple mineral deficient
disease starts as osteopenia
osteoporosis arthritis you generous
rightis bone to bone arthritis all the
same diseases different degrees in
severity and you know one begets the
other as you go along if you know it
would solve the problem we have the
healthy bone and joint pack for that one
400 pounds of body weight and there's
four ingredients in there so you have to
give a full dose of all the ingredients
twice a day if for a 200-pound person
but I like I've over 150 pounds I like
them to have 15 of the glucose yellow
day which are the raw materials to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone matrix moment self it's
actually a mix of chondroitin sulfate
glucosamine sulfate hyaluronic acid and
collagen it's all them one capsules this
was the main message in the dead doctors
don't why all your cassette-tape back in
1992 and that came out and of course one
guy branded me with that audio cassette
tape I never thought my wildest dreams
that would be a big deal but one guy
about 20 million of them for a buck
apiece his check cleared it was really
weird he got excited about it so I
thought man this must be something and
since then I've sold 180 million so you
need to kind of change your stories 180
million now they're still going out the
store at fifty thousand a week now five
percent of arthritis is rheumatoid
arthritis five percent has rheumatoid
arthritis
brooch arthritis is easily curable in
two weeks Bouchard surprises a simple
infection with a bug called mycoplasma
michael plasma is the cause of
rheumatoid arthritis is not our
immunised out of genetic disease is not
just dumb luck is not somebody's put a
hex on you it's just a simple infection
it's curable in two weeks for the
antibiotic called minocycline like the
little baitfish minocycline take that
minocycline it's gone you're still going
to have some damage so it might take you
sixty ninety days depending on the
degree of damage the healthy bone and
joint pack to regrow everything then
you're done with it now the doctor will
only make three hundred dollars in
office calls if he cures you with that
program thermoses might make a few bucks
from the minocycline prescription you've
heard of minocycline as a member of the
tetracycline family insurer if he treats
you for 25 years he makes $750,000 joint
replacements all the side effects of the
drugs got treat and so he has to think
for three tenths of a millisecond am I
gonna make 300 bucks am I gonna make
750,000 which way do they all go there
I'm a monopoly no competition and
insurance pays but it wasn't insurance
you wouldn't mortgage your house for
$750,000 you just take more aspirin or
you take grandma's herbs all ready to
take healthy bone and joint pet but
insurance pays well I've got it
management you know the doctor said the
insurance will pay for my heart
replacement some go in that direction I
wouldn't want to spend $3 a day I need
it for my Starbucks coffee okay this is
Andy Young's living room I was kind of
40 pounds heavier there but he'd
canceled his dull knee replacement and
we rebuilt his knees in 90 days and he's
been a very good friend of mine ever
since this gal here was in a wheelchair
for ten years before I met her you
recognize some of these folks this gal
here his name is Willie Barrow anybody
recognize that name Willie Barrow Willie
barrel was dr. King's accountant she
made sure that not a single penny was
stolen from the Civil Rights movie never
heard of any anything going there was no
mischief with the money with a civil
rights movement and she was the one that
kept control of everything
well that was invited in to be this the
featured speaker her 87th birthday party
okay it was at the Rainbow PUSH facility
and ten days she's 87 years old ten days
after she's on her program she got on
that wheelchair and walk for the first
time in ten years the coming epidemic of
arthritis wiser an epidemic bozer's 80
million baby boomers come along and they
followed the doctor's directions they
exercised they drank plenty of water and
didn't take vitamins and minerals it's a
perfect storm for obesity diabetes
arthritis
al-harazi's oh yeah be sure to take the
standard rose
July 2002 the New England Journal of
Medicine Harvard Medical School a team
of artha peak surgeons apartment Michael
school did a meta study on 300,000
people from around the world that it had
don't replace when they said
knee surgery hip surgery and shoulder
surgery arthritis is worthless give me
90 days give us 90 days if you have
anything along the line osteopenia
osteoporosis arthritis degenerate is
bone of arthritis no to the surgery
suggestion do not do it artha peak
surgery arthroscopic surgery
replacements are do not do it give me 90
days first you can always get the
surgery can't you but III was personally
met a kid who's seven foot ten he's a
high school kid seven foot ten in
Chicago his father's on the suicide
watch as we speak he had a little funny
feeling at the end of his high school
days here on the other side of his right
knee and and the father says look the
coach has an in with the orthopedic
surgeon that the Chicago Bulls if he
looks at she might get on that team the
kids I don't know I I don't feel good
about that if I said oh let's talk about
so he goes in there in the guy saw we
need you arthroscopic sword I was
scraped the cartilage and everything
would be fine he gives a kid mersa they
put in a hyperbaric chamber for you know
two months and game IV antibiotics and
they wound up cutting his leg off now
how do you play basketball with one and
a half legs and the doctor gets a walk
so I could have fixed that kid and I
can't regrow his leg if he was a
salamander I could some of you know
enough about biology okay four years
later in November 2006 the same group of
doctors from Harvard Medical School
orthopedic surgeons published in the
journal American Medical Association
said surgery unnecessary for sciatica
low back pain peripheral neuropathies
numbness burning pain in the feet
bulging discs ruptured discs restless
leg syndrome any of that kind of stuff
all in necessary give me 90 days we
regrow discs we fix backs all the time
do not get sore you can always get the
surgery that's what Andy Young said but
you can't fix me 98 I'll just go get the
surgery you know I'm willing to take you
know it's been suffering with us for 25
years or was another couple of months
okay type-2 diabetes is a simple mineral
deficiency wise our gonna be a type two
diabetes epidemic 80 million baby
boomers come along extras I drink plenty
of water and don't take vitamins and
minerals it's a simple mineral
deficiencies disease and so we have what
we call the healthy blood sugar PEC you
take one healthy blood sugar pack per
hundred pounds of body weight and take
your fasting blood sure every morning
before you medicate yourself close
you can have your blood sugar 300 every
morning with medication with injectable
insulin and if you take our program the
night before it could be 68 the next day
so don't medicate yourself without
taking your passing blood sugar first I
don't get the easy ones I would get the
tough ones okay this is gangrene to the
foot again with gangrene to the foot
again with gangrene of the legs this
fella here his name is buck Stefan's
came to me he was 260 pounds his blood
shirt was 371 with injectable insulin
doctors told him he was gonna die within
three months he was so bad with diabetes
and all this side effects complications
that whether they took his feet off or
not he's gonna die in three months if
they de amputate his feet he's gonna die
if they didn't amputate his feet so he
sold his house moved up to Eugene Oregon
with his family so he had spent his last
weeks or months with his family but he
came to a convention of ours and I told
look you have nothing looser 260 pound
guy won she won three healthy bone and
she's got three healthy blood sugar
packs which he did and in six weeks time
his blood sugar instead of being 371
with injectable insulin that was in fact
than 68 he's an ex diabetic we gave him
addition to that we gave him nine of our
ultimate daily tablets he had
circulation down through that foot we
put in our colloidal silver soaked on
cotton balls in between his toes put a
clean cotton sock on there change that
dressing four times a day and a two
months time that's the same foot saved
both his feet he's perfectly normal now
an ex diabetic we can make America
diabetes free in 60 90 days playing safe
somebody has to have the will to do it
we have the ability to do it give me 90
days for you just keep taking your
antibiotics keep that gangrene from
getting worse and give me some time and
the odds are we'll be able to fix this
do not get amputations first without
trying something else if it's not
cholesterol the clogs your arteries what
is it is the inflammation where he
talked about the inflammation from fried
foods processed meats with nitrates and
nitrites oils and in many cases gluten
wheat barley round oats
okay now this fella here is a pasture
you may know him he's he's the pastor of
a bit of a very big black church he's
300 pounds and
this picture he I met him at one o'clock
in the morning in the lobby of a hotel
he brought a letter of introduction from
Martin Luther King the third and Martin
I worked with Martin for a long time
and he was on the heart-transplant list
he actually had a bracelet he says if
this thing starts buzzing the lights
going off just like that thing they give
you and a restaurant waiting for a table
he says this thing goes off starts
buzzing the light started blinking I'm
out of here don't think I'm rude but I
have I'm on the heart-transplant list
I have congestive heart fair which is a
defendant say this I'm telling you this
he had congestive heart failure buddy
which is an efficiency of a single
vitamin he's curable in a couple of
weeks congestive heart filled the most
common cause of heart death in America's
deficiency of a single my vitamins
curable in a couple of weeks a selenium
is for the other disease he had Salim is
a mineral and he had it it was a
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease was a deficiency of a single
mineral selenium Ellis had coronary
artery disease which is caused by
inflammation in that fried chicken after
church every Sunday right he was a big
man so ate a lot of it and he brought a
briefcase kind of this size and it had
27 prescription drugs in there he was
taken three of those prescription drugs
were diuretics one of which was lasix
and he couldn't walk from here that wall
without holding on to the chairs now
Lobby you want to get a cup of coffee
and he's well he stopped every two or
three chairs empty had so much fluid in
his chest in his belly that tells me
immediately that those those diuretics
weren't working that's because he wasn't
absorbing them he had a gluten
intolerance it wasn't absorbing the
medicine he run into people who say well
yeah I can take a thousand aspirins it
doesn't work by Agatha's terrible
headache it won't work they got a gluten
in times they just can't absorb them
you're not what you eat you are which
absorbed it's kind of different than the
old adage you are which heat is really
your which absorb so if you can't absorb
it no matter what you're doing for good
it doesn't matter you have to be able to
absorb it so anyway at twenty-seven
prescription drugs okay look I'm gonna
treat you for all hor of all for heart
diseases and I didn't have at that time
this was six years ago I didn't have the
ASAP at that time says it'll look what I
want you to do is take three of the
healthy heart and brain packs per month
here we've taken three doses a day of
six different vitamin products just from
that
as your basic stuff your body needs I'm
gonna have you take nine in my selenium
add a sweet breakfast lunch and there
are the three bottles a month I want you
to take 12 of the ultimate daily tale is
four four and four there's two bottles a
month because they're big bottles
because we got to deal with the clogged
arteries because you have coronary
artery disease then I want you to take
the slim was for the cardiomyopathy
heart disease then for the congestive
heart failure I want you to take what we
call the D stress capsules which has
that one vitamin dismissing when you
have the congestive heart failure which
you take 12 of those a day as your
primary disease there'll be three
bottles a month and then you got to give
up the fried foods and the processed
meats and the nitrates and nitrites the
oils and the gluten a wheat bran around
oats he's hanging tuna that's too
complicated all that stuff and and died
changed his wife is only a hundred
pounds her name is you're gonna do it
she says you're even do it if you're
gonna do it not gonna do it I'm gonna
give it to you rectally he says okay
I'll do it I never seen anybody talk to
a pastor like that but she did it and
got away with it okay she was so angry
with him that he said it was too
complicated so I told call me every two
weeks that's my deal call me in two
weeks she calls me in a week that frie
this was Sunday morning one o'clock she
called me this is God's truth as a
pastor you could generate she called me
a week later she says he went in this
morning he'd been taking a physical
every Friday for three years because
they told him he has so many
complication it had to be a train wreck
in Chicago and 500 dead people for him
to get a heart he's so low in a list and
I said we got to do a physical on you
every Friday so we have a running
knowledge of how you are so when the
heart comes in we don't want to dine in
the ice bucket waiting for a lab test
we're gonna slam the heart in you if it
comes he paid him $5,000 cash every
Friday for three years twenty thousand
dollars a month cash do you think they
weren't using him for an ATM machine
they were giggling all the way to the
country club every Friday okay
so any rate he goes in they call his
wife say look your husband didn't turn
on his cell phone we want you to turn
around send him back do not give him
anything do not give him when he comes
home do not give him anything trimmer
I'm sending back give him five thousand
dollars gonna redo everything he thinks
we think we've mixed all his dad up with
somebody else's so you know what's
happening already right so
he goes in he thought he won the lottery
because now it was his cardiologist
there's another cardiologist and there
was three heart transplant surgeons he
needed met before he says they got my
heart they got my heart this is it they
did all the tests again they took him
off of all 27 per scription drugs he
took him off the heart transplant list
and deemed him cured and now he is
preaching before he couldn't preach he
had to sit you know on the stage and
then he had an assistant pastor preach
for like five years because he couldn't
preach he couldn't breathe it was so
full of fluid
do not let your pediatricians give your
kids statin drugs they're talking about
starting at eight years old the American
Academy of Pediatrics has now released
new guidelines then once the kids that
have low fat milk and take start
cholesterol testing and they want them
to take statin drugs do not let them do
it because these kids will not live to
be 20 if they start on statin drugs at 8
now this is my favorite this is the last
one on cholesterol then I could talk
about high blood pressure which is very
very good that I'm done in my favorite
cholesterol article scientific article
New England Journal of Medicine Harvard
Medical School dr. Kern was the
professor of clinical medicine at
Harvard Medical Students how to be a
doctor in the outpatient clinic normal
cholesterol an 88 year old man Frank who
eats 25 eggs a day he comes in for his
annual physical there's like a dozen
students around dr. Kern and he said
look we are so proud of you you're 88
years old all your chemistries are
normal I mean it's just really an
interesting and so we want to reward you
we're gonna we've decided since we get
lots of free samples everything we're
gonna give you a free supply a one-year
free supply of Viagra and he he stands
up he puts his you know picks his belt
up throws the shoulders back said I
don't need none of that viagra stuff I'm
pretty good in that area there really
and all the students are giggling you
know and because I called dr. Kern and
asked him he said well the students are
really giggling over that one and I said
well what makes you so sure you're in
good shape over that and he says well I
ate 25 eggs a day and you can imagine
dr. Kern a medical doctor from Harvard
somebody eaten 25 eggs and their
cholesterol is in the normal range he's
got to have a heart attack right so they
all run in the lab they rerun all the
blood and sure enough it's still normal
comes back out he's sitting down he says
he's patting his brown with his
handkerchief cause he's sweating so
okay tell me why eat 25 eggs a days so
Frank stands up again pulls his bow and
belt up throws the shoulder back says
because it makes me more studly I are a
stud now know what you think about it
cholesterol makes up 95% of testosterone
if you're on egg free diet there ain't
nobody home you're eating 25 eggs a day
okay high blood pressure quickly is not
a genetic disease
a simple mineral deficiency salt has
nothing to do with habit pressure if you
swell up you get a demon when you use
salt as because you have a low blood
protein eat more eggs get your protein
up you won't have the swelling after
years of telling healthy people the too
much salt isn't good for the researchers
still don't have solid evidence to back
up the claim doctors say the stupidest
things constantly like there's no
prevention for alzheimers disease okay
so you know I'm a farmer and so you put
a salt block out and pasture for cows
and horses and whatnot is there anybody
out there telling a horse or cow they're
limited to one lick a day no I refuse to
believe my patients my human patients
are dumber than a cow so you just saw
your food just salted salted salted salt
to go crazy bathe in it salted put under
your arms putting your ears put salt
everywhere go for salt said God says go
forth and be as a salt of the earth and
he lives forever doctors say restrict
salt may only live to be 56 I'm going
with God on the salt thing so there's
two things you need to do in addition to
firing your doctor it starts for this
share on the American Medical
Association August 2003 they talked
about an herb called dark chocolate not
milk chocolate dark chocolate it has a
substance to call flavanols with lower
blood pressure now it doesn't give you
the mineral that will permanently cure
it but it will lower it like a
pharmaceutical will without the
complications of pharmaceuticals as
flavanols in the dark chocolate okay
so when that came out 2003 we came out
with a liquid dark chocolate called
cocoa Java t plus it has the flavanols
in it plus 3,000 of those auric points
in a brown so you take two ounce a day
we're a coffee company but we sell
organic coffee and so we want you to put
an ounce of this twice a day in your cup
of organic coffee make your own mocha
cafe right why give Howard all the money
do it yourself plus you get the
flavanols to lower your blood pressure
without the complications of the
pharmaceuticals we also have pieces of
chocolate each the size of
out of butter come in boxes of 100 or 20
it's a little cheaper and boxes of 100
cuz there's less packaging each piece
the size of a pad of butter has the
flavanols in it to lower your blood
pressure is gluten-free glycemic
friendly even diabetics can take it two
of these will give you thirty three
thousand of those auric points so I take
six of these a day I never take less
than six today so I get a hundred
thousand auric points remember the
longer people taking 20,000 to 50,000
Americans takin 1500 I'd taken a hundred
thousand I'm gonna end my presentation
with a little summary here it goes like
this if I were to live to be 112 nobody
would pay attention to it they'd say
well you know while I can't claim that's
his stuff because people would be 112
all the time so I have to live to be 200
I'm pointing to center field I'm
pointing to center field like Babe Ruth
right I'm pointing to center field and
I'm saying I'm going for 200 finally
make it 279 that'll still be better than
hundred twelve right
but to get 279 I got to shoot for 200 so
I'm pointing to center field and
remember here's Babe Ruth two outs two
strikes and at bottom of the ninth and
they're down by three runs he steps out
of the batter's box
you know knocks the mud off his cleats
and he points out to center field
everybody including the pitcher knew
what he was talking about he's going for
a Grand Slam so he win by one run they
were down by three runs that pitcher he
was smart he'd had just thrown a ball
into the dirt and walked him he could
probably handle the next batter but
instead he's too arrogant and he threw
that pitch and Babe Ruth hit that grand
slam and they won by one run I'm
pointing to center field say I'm going
for 200 ok now I'm doing everything
right again and these people live with
me they eat with me we spend a lot of
time I give 300 lectures a year they'll
be with me for a couple of days and they
pass me up to somebody else it'll be
with me a couple of a they pass known as
a meal so I eat with a lot of people and
they see me take my stuff every day I do
it twice a day been taking the 90s
entrance twice a day since I was nine
that's why I'm into a doctor in 65 years
I don't have any health problems I have
no health problems okay so the message
here is I started doing it when I was
nine I mean you can start now alright I
have four kids eight grandkids and four
great grandkids they're all the stuff
before they're conceived all through
their pregnancy and from the moment
they're born not I've never been sick
none of my kids my grandkids my great
fans have ever been sick so the point is
if we all do this basic
thing avoid the bad stuff the fried
foods the processed meats with nitrates
and nitrites the oils the salad
dressings a mayonnaise the cooking oils
vite canned fish it's fine but heat
impact in water mustard tomato sauce not
oil use your brains use your heart save
your families you have to do these
things and if we we can save America but
we're gonna have to do it we can't wait
on the doctors to make up their minds
they're gonna be a thousand years behind
it took him a thousand years to give up
the idea that diseases caused by evil
spirits and so to take him a thousand
years to give up the genetics even
though that the guy who got the Nobel
Prize for it said it's not genetics it's
vitamins and minerals okay you're gonna
have to take the ball and run with it if
you do that we can save ourselves if you
don't do that you will be burying your
children as it comes down to all right
so we're looking for lots of help I'm
not here just to sell another bottle of
minerals I don't make any money
personally from selling minerals and
things I do these lectures for free I
make my living from selling books and so
I did that purposely so doctors couldn't
take away from the message well he's
selling them vitamins minerals he'll
tell you anything to sell them in
vitamins as well I don't make anything
from it I purposely don't so they can't
say that and so we're looking for lots
of help we're in a major growth phase
right now because the medical system is
having troubles of its own the
government is in trouble financially and
the economy's in trouble financially and
so people are coming to us now who
wouldn't have looked at us before we not
I mean eat lots of help and we give car
bonuses and stock options we give tax
benefits because you own your own
business you can't get these tax
benefits when you're a good employee you
have no tax benefits when you're a good
employee but when you're when you own
your own business even a little ten
dollar business like youngevity you
actually can get tat you can get back
most of your withholdings so is that for
one time a one-time fee at ten dollars
every year get back thousands of dollars
whoa we don't have to think about that
for three seconds pretty simple stuff
okay so it doesn't get any better than
that god bless you all thank you very
much thank you for viewing this
presentation and remember to contact the
person that sent this to you for more
presentations and books that go into
greater detail go to doc Wallach
Mediacom and be well these statements
have not been evaluated by the FDA these
products are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease the
opinions expressed in this informational
program are the Express opinions of Joel
D Wallach BSD VM and D are not a
replacement for proper medical advice
and treatment in all cases we recommend
you contact your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions